this is a production of cornell
university
okay it's 901 uh let's get started
welcome again everyone uh to our
cornell hemp research team virtual field
day
it's a beautiful day here in upstate new
york and i wish you
all could be here we would have had a
perfect day in the field
but i'm going to look at the silver
lining
and that is that we are now up to 213
attendees
uh already matching what we had last
year and that was our max capacity of
our
field facilities we've also been able to
[Music]
encourage the participation of people
across the country and perhaps around
the world
through this virtual format so i think
we're going to have a broader impact
we have a good lineup of speakers today
we you see we've broken up the session
the program into three sessions
the first one on hemp reading and
genetics second on crop management
and the third on supply chains and
regulatory updates
some of those presentations will be made
live some are pre-recorded
and i will play those through my
computer we've allowed
a five-minute break at the end of each
hour because we've realized now with
these long zoom meetings that
people need uh to take a break for a few
minutes get a cup of coffee
use the restroom etc so
i also want to thank our uh support from
texas international
and some of my colleagues from pixas are
on as well
they have sponsored our research now for
the second season
and have made a strong commitment to
extension and outreach to
hemp growers across the country so again
i want to thank them
so without further ado i'm going to turn
the screen over to
my graduate student george stack who is
starting the second year of his phd
who is going to give you a presentation
about
some of our cannabinoid hemp
trials george
okay can everybody hear me fire can you
hear me yep i hear you well
okay
and you can see my screen yep looks
perfect
okay as larry said my name is george
stack and i'm starting the second year
of my phd in this lab at cornell
agritech today i'm going to be talking
to you about
our high cannabinoid hemp cultivar
trials from 2019
and 2020. before i kind of dig
in i'd like to bring up two points one
is that i have posted two fact sheets
on our website one about the 2019 trial
and one about the 2020 trial so there's
data that i'm going to be presenting in
this talk as well as additional data
that you can check out there and the
second thing i'd like to bring up
is that when i talk about thc in this
talk i'm talking about total thc
so this is a regulatory issue that i
don't really have time to dig into right
now but we'll hopefully
discuss uh it later in the
in the field day excuse me um
so before i talk about the data we need
to understand
why different cannabis plants accumulate
different cannabinoids
and it comes down to this cannabinoid
biosynthetic pathway right here
i'm going to put my pointer on so we're
starting with these precursor compounds
that get converted into cbga
and then the cbga can get converted into
either cbda
by the cbda synthase enzyme in the plant
or thca by the thc a synthase enzyme in
the plant
and the combination of these two enzymes
that a plant has really dictate
what cannabinoids it's going to
accumulate so you can imagine
if we have a thca synthase enzyme but no
cbda synthase enzyme
the plant will accumulate thc and this
is called
chemotype 1. if we have both
a thca synthase enzyme and a cbda
synthase enzyme we'll accumulate both
cbda and thca this is called chemotype
2. if we have just a cbda synthase
enzyme
and no thca synthase enzyme will
accumulate cbd
this is called chemotype 3 and if we
have
neither a cbda synthase enzyme nor a
thca synthase enzyme will accumulate cbg
and this is how you get these high cbg
varieties and this is called chemotype
4.
so let's look at this in the context of
our 2019 cbd cultivar trial
this trial was replicated at two sites
one in geneva
and one in ithaca at each of these sites
we had 30 cultivars replicated
and so one of the questions that we can
ask about the trial is what chemotypes
showed up in this 2019
trial were all of the plants chemotype 3
high cbd plants as we would expect if
we're trying to produce cbd
and the answer to that question is no so
at least 7 of the 30 cultivars were not
all chemotype 3.
so this is some cannabinoid data from
one cultivar that had chemotypes 1
2 and 3 individuals in it and you can
see that the chemotype 1
and chemotype 2 individuals accumulated
a lot of thc
and exceeded the regulatory threshold so
this is a real problem that growers are
being sold chemotype 1 and 2 plants when
they're expecting chemotype 3 plants and
it causes them to be not compliant
the second question that we asked was
how do cannabinoids accumulate
over time and we did this by taking
shoot tip samples
weekly after terminal flowering for all
of the 30 cultivars
and when we look at the data it looks
like this so let's look at cbd
accumulation over time we have c
total potential cbd on our y-axis here
and we have weeks after terminal
flowering on our x-axis
each of these lines is a different one
of the cultivars
and shows how it accumulates cbd over
time
so you can see that for most cultivars
they accumulate quite a lot of cbd
in the weeks immediately following
terminal flowering and this makes sense
because most of the cannabinoids are
concentrated
in the trichomes of the female flowers
what's really interesting though is when
you compare this graph of cbd
accumulation
to the graph of thc accumulation and
i'll just flip back and forth between
these slides a few times here
and you can see that the curves for each
of the cultivars are almost
identical it's just the scales are
different so the scale for the cbd graph
was 0 to 20
and the scale for this thc graph is 0 to
0.6
and the reason the curves are so similar
is because
cbd and thc accumulation are coupled
in high cbd plants at a fixed ratio
and unfortunately that means these
cultivars here that accumulated
high levels of cbd also accumulated
enough thc to be above this 0.3
total thc legal threshold which leaves
us a very small window
to do regulatory testing and harvest
before our cultivars become not
compliant
and when we look at this cbd to thc
ratio across all of our cultivars we
have
cbd to thc ratio on our y-axis here
our cultivars on our x-axis we see that
it's pretty consistent for most
cultivars
between a 20 to 1 ratio and 31
30 to 1 ratio excuse me and that means
that at a 0.3 percent total thc
threshold uh on average we can only
accumulate about
seven to eight percent total cbd before
a plant becomes not compliant the third
thing i'd like to talk about is when
these plants flowered and the variation
in flowering time
so in this graph here you can see our
cultivars on the y-axis
and the date on the x-axis this vertical
line
is when we transplanted and uh you can
see that these bars indicate when each
of the cultivars flowered
so we had some that flowered in june
some in july
some in august some in september and one
even in october
and i've added these circle x's to show
when these cultivars exceeded the 0.3
total thc legal threshold and you can
see
that it's very strongly correlated and
has this
this one two maybe four week window
between terminal flowering and exceeding
the thc
threshold for most cultivars
in summary i'm going to talk about
considerations for staying thc compliant
with growing for cbd
the first thing we talked about were the
different chemotypes of cannabis
and how when we're producing cbd we
really want chemotype 3 plants
the second thing we talked about was the
cannabinoid accumulation curves
and so i'm going to stress the
importance of regular testing
to make sure that you know where you are
on that curve and that you're staying
under the 0.3
legal threshold and the third thing i
mentioned
was that flowering was very strongly
correlated with
cannabinoid accumulation which makes
sense because cannabinoids are
accumulated in the trichomes
of the female flowers so monitoring
flowering time
is a really good management strategy for
staying under that thc
threshold now i'm going to briefly talk
about our
cultivar trials from this year so we
have a cbd cultivar
trial and a cvg cultivar trial so this
is
chemotype 3 and chemotype 4.
again we've replicated at two sites one
in geneva
and one in ithaca so just to circle
around here
in geneva we have a cbd trial with 40
different cultivars in it
and we also have a cbg trial with 12
different cultivars in it
and over here in ithaca we have a
replicated
cbd trial with 32 of the cultivars in it
and we also have a direct seeded
essential oil hemp trial which is a
multi-state trial organized by oregon
state
and this has nine cultivars in it so
i'll just share some
preliminary data here from our cbd and
cvg
cultivar trials so as of monday 21 of
the 52 cultivars have started to
terminally flower
and i've represented that that flowering
time in this plot over here
so this is called a violin plot and it
shows the distribution
of flowering over the course of
the last two months or so and you can
see
that some cultivars seem to have several
distinct
groups of flowering time some early some
late
several appear to flower just over the
course of multiple weeks but not be
really separated into groups
and some all flower very consistently at
the same time
so it'll be interesting to see how these
cultivars
continue to mature over the rest of the
growing season and how
the other 31 cultivars that haven't
flowered yet
will fit into this scheme so i'll just
say thank you to all the people who
contributed to this research
and our funding sources please put your
questions in the chat
and i'd be happy to answer them and this
is my contact info if you'd like to talk
more about him
thank you
that's great thanks very much george
we're going to try to get
on time here and make sure that my
sharing of the videos here
is working we have time for q
a at the end of the hour so i think
there will be plenty of time for george
to answer your questions
so it's my pleasure now to introduce
jacob toth
another phd student in my lab
who will give you a complimentary talk
on our molecular breeding for a
compliant fiber type
hello and welcome everybody to the
cornell hemp field days my name is jacob
toast and i'm a phd candidate in larry's
smart clap and today i'll be talking
about molecular bleeding of hemp
for my talk today i'll be discussing
some of the
theory and ideas behind molecular
breeding attempt
and give an example of how we're using
molecular breeding in our research
program to develop a high yielding
fiber cultivar that has low levels of
thc to stay compliant as well as produce
high levels of cbd
it is important to recognize the
contribution of genetics and environment
to your trait of interest
for any breeding endeavor so how the
plant grows
the phenotype is there about there's the
result of both
the genetics of the plant as well as the
environment
the genetics of the plant also known as
the genotype
refers to the dna of the plants
the genes and other dna which make up
the plant's genome
so many important traits such as yields
are heavily influenced by both the
genotype and the environment
but some traits such as photoperiod
dependence and cannabinoid
are heavily influenced by genotype alone
concerning photoperiod dependence if you
look at this picture here
the small plant is photoperiod
independent and started flowering
almost immediately after planting while
the larger plant
which is fully period dependent didn't
start flowering until
the night length hit a certain threshold
so another important trait that is
influenced heavily by genotype
in cannabis is cannabinoid type and
breeding for cannabinoid type is a
fundamental part of any hemp breeding
so what is molecular breeding so
in molecular breeding very broadly
instead of just looking at the phenotype
of the plant which is the result of both
the genotype and the environment
you look at the actual dna
so advances in molecular biology have
allowed
much easier analysis of dna
and because the dna is the same in every
cell
of a plant whether it's young or whether
it's old
being able to assay a plant just by
looking at the dna allows you
to look at certain traits before they're
even expressed
for instance to determine if a plant is
going to be male or female or if it's
going to produce mostly thc or mostly
cbd
[Music]
so with molecular breeding you can
develop new cultivars based on the
genotype alone
and when done accurately this can result
in less expensive phenotyping
and ultimately reducing the cost and
reducing the time it takes
to develop a new cultivar
now i'm going to talk a little bit about
how our research group is using
molecular breeding to develop
new elite high yielding fiber cultivars
that have compliant levels of thc
in 2019 we grew several varieties for
grain and fiber production
including two cultivars from china
called dama and puma
we didn't know much about these
cultivars when we first planted them
aside from
a little blurb for puma which claimed to
have
high cbd seeds high leaves and flowers
output
when these plants were grown we were
quite impressed by the plants
in that they had extremely large leaves
and extremely fast growth rate
and would routinely hit 10 feet tall
when we harvested these plants and
breaded them to measure the fiber yields
we found that vaman puma had nearly
doubled the biomass yield of other elite
cultivars grown for fiber
because of this we thought that the puma
would make excellent fiber cultivators
however when we looked at the
cannabinoids
we found that both puma and bama
produced thc at levels exceeding 0.3
and would be non-compliant in the modern
regulatory framework
we looked further at the cannabinoids
that puma and bama were producing and we
found that they were relatively high in
cannabinoids
with puma producing a little over 1.5
percent
total cannabinoids and dama sometimes
exceeding 2
total cannabinoids this is considerably
higher than
what other fiber cultivars produced in
terms of total cannabinoids
additionally we sampled these plants
when they were just starting to flower
so we hypothesized that as the plant
became more mature
the total cannabinoids would increase
even further however the big problem was
that puma and bama produced
thc as a major cannabinoid which isn't
what we wanted so ultimately
what we would like in a cultivar would
be something that produces as much dry
biomass as
puma and bama but instead of producing
thc
produces cbd and to achieve that goal
we turn to molecular breeding
so to understand what we did for
molecular breeding it's first
important to understand the different
chemotypes that are found
in cannabis so there are
three important chemotypes that i'll
talk about right now there's type 1
which is
mostly thc there's type 2 which is cbd
to thc at about a 2
1 ratio but this number can vary
and then there's type 3 which produces
mostly cbd
so if you're growing a population or a
cultivar
for cbd you'd expect all the plants to
be type 3
but in 2018 and 2019 we found that some
of the plants
that we were growing were in fact type 2
or even type 1 producing almost no cbd
using this data and this figure in the
top here shows
data from 2018 we developed a molecular
marker which looks at the dna of the
plants
and can distinguish type 1 from type 2
and type
3 planets so getting back to bama and
puma
when we were looking at the thc to cbd
ratio
for these plants we saw that it was
about a 2 1 ratio of cbd to thc
which would suggest that most of the
plants that we were sampling
were type 2 so an interesting thing
about these type 2 plants is that they
won't breed true
if there's a population which is freely
inter-crossing with a lot of these type
2 plants you'd expect to see
a certain number to be type 1 and a
certain number to be type
3. so we didn't have the
hplc the chemical data on a lot of
different
plants from bama and puma we were just
looking at pooled samples
but we could apply this molecular marker
to
these populations and distinguish the
different plants
that were in these different chemotypes
so late last year around december we
grew about a hundred plants each of bama
and puma and tested them with this
marker that we developed
and as expected we found that about half
of the plants
were type two and we found that about a
third of the plants were type
three and then the remainder were type
one
so what we did was we selected the type
three
and in theory these plants should form
an excellent basis
for a high producing fiber cultivar
that produces mostly cbd
however after selection of these type 3
plants
we run into a few problems with their
propagation so these plants which are so
vigorous in the field are also very
vigorous in a greenhouse
and they grew extremely fast and
extremely tall sometimes in excess of 14
feet they were also quite susceptible
to various greenhouse pathogens such as
thrips and spider mites
to make matters worse they appear to be
very photoperiod dependent
and did not flower in the greenhouse in
the spring when we were growing them
there were also some issues with cutting
propagation
these plants form a very nice single
stem as you can see in this photo here
but it's not always simple to take a
cutting and root
that very nice stem so to address this
we're attempting to grow the plants in
the field we've planted them out
and hopefully we'll harvest some grain
at the end of the season which will form
a good basis for scale-up
and we've also sent the cuttings of
these plants
to a collaborator in florida who should
be able
to grow the plants without any issue
in summary molecular breathing involves
selection
on the genotype on the dna directly
familiar and puma two cultivars from
china
are high biomass producers but they
produce high
non-compliant levels of thc
selection in bama and puma for chemotype
3 plants using a molecular marker should
produce
a high yielding compliant thyroculture
these plants here growing in the field
in new york should
form the basis of a new compliant fiber
cultivar
we hope to harvest the seeds at the end
of the season scale them up
ensure that the resultant plants have
the same biomass
potential as their parent bama and puma
populations
and eventually potentially release new
cultivars
okay thanks very much jacob uh we are
now
going to switch to uh my postdoc
craig carlson uh who is out at the field
in our one of our breeding trials so
craig is going to talk about uh
some f1 hybrids that he has produced and
show you some of their traits
alrighty larry can you see me
yes we can all right hello everybody
my name is craig carlson i'm a post-doc
with cornell hemp
uh i work on breeding genetics and
genomics of him
and i've got chris smart here with me
recording and we are
more than six feet apart so uh
let's get this uh let's get this thing
rolling
uh so uh if you've been with the hemp
industry for about three or four
years uh you'll know that there is a big
need for cultivar development
for many years we've seen a
uniformity in the field in grain and
fiber cultivars
but we've also seen a lot of uh
issues with uniformity in uh high
cannabinoid cultivars
so we're standing in our breeding and
selection trial right now
and this trial consists of 24 families
uh of 24 individuals
uh crossed with a common parent tj
and that's owned by stem holdings it's
been kind of our
model hemp plant for the past three or
four years
so typically when we conduct these high
cannabinoid trials
uh we'll space plants about four feet
apart and have about six foot
alleys we'll do
weekly measurements of plant height
we'll look at leaf area
branching angle number of nodes
within the canopy uh plant
canopy width and so we can get a nice
shape descriptor for those individuals
that's what i've seen is really lacking
in the literature uh is
uh uh is
shape descriptors that are very basic
right so tree form you know globe shape
columnar etc uh
so all of these uh families
have been crossed with tj or an inbred
s1 or s2 of tj what i want to show you
is how some of these phenotypes are
segregating in these families
because tj is actually quite
heterozygous
uh but the parents are heterozygous to
more inbred i want to show you kind of
what our important traits
are doing in the field and
the differences between crossing
heterozygous with heterozygous
and heterozygous with inbred material so
if we can get chris to move over here
uh this this row right here is
a tj's s2 meaning that we
self tjs using sts
to produce pollen silver thiosulfate
selected an individual and then
self that progeny from that individual
so it's an s2 population
and what i was going for with this
family was to select an s1
that looked a lot more like the parent
uh
but what we are finding out what we have
found
out is that uh tj's actually
heterozygous
for a flowering time gene
and so this is an s2 family in this row
and what we see is that a lot of these
early flowering
individuals are fairly uniform
and many of the later flowering
individuals are fairly uniform
so there is some uniformity but
it's just so dramatic what differences
in flowering
time can do to a family
so if we want to come over here chris
we're going to look at another family
another s2
and okay
all right chris this is this is tj this
is
that common parent of all of these up
ones
it has a really irregular shape to it
kind of drooping leaves it's a high
cannabinoid uh
hemp type i also in that s1 made a
selection
of a early flowering individual
so it's kind of homozygous for that
flowering time gene
and as you can see it's far more uniform
besides differences really in maybe
plant size
but small differences in plant size
and it's far more uniform that than that
other s1 that was segregating for the
flowering time locus
there are some uh really interesting
uh families uh
yeah okay they got dropped again uh
so we are going to move on uh to our
next presentation
chris we're gonna move on yeah we're
gonna move on
we're gonna move on
okay uh and craig is gonna run into the
uh office here so he can join our q a
uh so our next presentation is from
jamie crawford good morning uh
who will be talking about our grain and
fiber trials
uh mostly in ithaca
so let me get that going for you
good morning everyone my name is jamie
crawford and i'll be giving you a brief
update
on our hemp grain and fiber trials
our trial design is a randomized
complete block where each entry is
replicated four times
plots are four feet wide and 20 feet
long and seating rate is calculated
based on the germination rate
and seed weight of each entry so the 25
seeds are planted per square foot in the
grain in dual trials
and 40 live seeds are planted per square
foot in the fiber trials
complete hemp grain and fiber reports
for each year can be found on our
website
but this graph shows the range of grain
yields in ithaca and geneva by year
the yields for 2017 and 2019 were quite
similar
ranging from seven to eight hundred
pounds per acre
for the lower yielding entries to
thirteen hundred to fourteen hundred
pounds per acre in the higher yielding
entries
decrease in yield in 2018 was due to the
timing of harvest
one location was harvested too early
before grain was mature
in all entries and one location was
harvested too late with much of the
grain lost to shattering our birds when
harvesting for grain
timing is very important fiber yields in
2017 were low due to poor seed quality
and very thin stands
with new higher germinating seed lots in
2018 and 2019
entries were yielding between five and
six dry tons per acre before reading
and two and a half to three and a half
dry tons per acre after
reading we established grain and fiber
trials in two locations this spring
the first in geneva planted on june 4th
and the second
planted in ithaca on june 6th ithaca had
received six tenths of an inch more rain
than in geneva
in the two weeks leading up to planting
and this made a huge difference in the
success of the trials
because the field was so dry when it was
prepped for planting
hard baked chunks of soil limited seed
soil contact
had we received the predicted rain it
could have been okay but the lack of
rain in the weeks after planting led to
poor emergence and then the trial was
overrun by
weeds the additional soil moisture at
the ithaca location
led to a finer seed bed excellent
emergence and what should have been an
excellent stand if our cone cedar hadn't
been slowly
breaking as we were planting
while we were planting the ithaca trials
the load bar which supported the packer
wheels was slowly twisting
planting some of the rose more deeply
and packing the soil over top of them
very
firmly we planted the fiber trial first
that day
and all six roads emerged but by the
last plot planted that day
only two rows emerged as expected the
planter was repaired
and then the grain and dual purpose
trials were replanted on june 24th
since these hemp varieties are
photoperiod sensitive
planting later leads to shorter plants
the tops of the signs in both pictures
are 30 inches from the ground
piccolo plant at the beginning of june
is close to four feet tall
piccolo planted the end of june is two
and a half feet tall
canola is over five feet tall in the
original planting and not quite four
feet tall in the replant
we expect the grain yields to be similar
between these trials
but shorter entries are more susceptible
to weed pressure
for my remaining time i'd like to show
you some pictures of
our trials here in ithaca new york we'll
start out with the fiber trial
the fiber trial was planted on june 6th
so it's from the original planting
and has four entries there are two new
entries this year the one on the left is
called yuma crossbow we had some
conflicting
information on whether it should be
included in the dual purpose or the
fiber trial
and as you can see here we made the
wrong choice
it's actually earlier flowering than
some of the entries
in our dual purpose trials and we will
be harvesting it for grain
later this month
the other new entry this year is jinma
and it is a little bit later maturing
than the italian varieties we have in
the trial as sort of our checks
and it's looking really good so far
our grain trial has eight entries
starting on the left with
x59 there's crs-1
in the middle and canda on the right
in this photo that's canada again on the
left followed by uso 31
in the middle and hinola on the right
and then finally this photo has picollo
on the left
joey in the middle and cfx
2 on the right
our dual purpose trials has 15
entries this year there on the left you
can see
nwg elite followed by nwg abound
and felina 32
in the second slide you see fedora 17
vega and then anka
this slide is futura 75
on the left alicia in the middle
and viabretsky on the right
this slide contains variety we're
calling h51
on the left ileana in the center
and rigel on the right
the final three entries in our dual
purpose trial
are altair on the left ferramon in the
middle
and voiko on the right
i'm so disappointed that we can't be
together in person to show off our
trials properly
when we've held field days in the past
i've noticed that people just cannot
help but touch and smell the plants
i can't send the smells of the hemp
field to you
but here is a video of one of our
technicians petting the hemp plots
for you to enjoy vicariously and with
that
i'll take any questions
okay thanks very much jamie
that was a great uh look at the
beautiful trials we have this year
in ithaca
unfortunately our trials here in geneva
suffered from the drought they don't
look
nearly as pretty as the ones in ithaca
so we have now come to our first q a
session
uh we're right on time so we have 15
minutes for live q
a and i am going to
i would encourage the panelists to
unmute their video
and i'm going to go through some of the
excellent questions we got in the chat
and start with uh george for this one
there's a very good question about how
you define
uh the start of flowering and
uh what we mean by
terminal flowering versus axillary
flowering
if you could elaborate on that a little
bit
yeah absolutely that's a great question
um so
one of the things that's challenging
about female flowering in hemp is that
not all of the cultivars flower in the
exact same way so their
their floral morphology is different um
so we defined terminal flowering as a
cluster of female flowers
at the shoot tips and we found that that
was a pretty
consistent way to mark all of the
cultivars at the same physiological
point
i will note that some cultivars do form
axillary flowers
just one single small female flower in
the axles of the leaves
a lot earlier but that is very variable
and is not a great indicator of when the
plants will start terminally flowering
yeah it it can get tricky definitely you
want to get
a loop or some other magnifying glass so
you can look at
the development of the trichomes as well
you want to see
the development from clear trichomes to
milky
and then to amber and that those will be
your cues
as to the uh time of maturity and the
time of harvest
uh jacob i'll point this one to you
there's a question about whether
we are breeding uh cultivars uh that are
high
in uh varan cannabinoids
or cbc as an example
um yes i'll answer that question so
last year we tested several varieties
and especially a few from china
had quite high variant concentrations
but just like as i was talking about
with bama and puma
they tended to mostly be th cv they
tended to be
mostly type 1 and type 2. we're actually
currently growing a large population
that we intend to screen with the
molecular marker
to pull out the type three plants and we
hope that those type three plants
in that population that produces a lot
of varins
will produce a lot of cbdv so in theory
if this works and you can get high
variance we may be able to develop a
dual purpose
cbdv grain or fiber cultivar
as for cdc we're seeing some very
interesting
results especially in some of these high
cbd cultivars
we have one that produced up to two
percent cbc
um we're currently working to understand
the basis of that production
um but at the moment we're not actively
working to create any
pure high cbc lines
and just to follow on there are a couple
more questions uh
that i'll aim at you regarding
cbg so maybe you could briefly describe
the genetic systems uh george did touch
on this
uh of how we get a high cbg line
and what would happen if that cbg line
were segregating for example uh
were heterozygous for an active thca
synthase
or was heterozygous for an active cbda
synthase
yeah i can answer that question so all
cannabinoids start off as cbga
so that's what it starts at and then if
there's an active
cbda or an active thca that
enzyme converts the cdga to thca or cbda
so in the absence of those enzymes you
get a cbga dominant plant
now if you have a plant that's
heterozygous for a cbda synthase or a
thca synthase
that's something that we're looking at
we're not 100 sure what the result will
be
it depends on the activity of this
enzyme if there's a lot of that enzyme
in this heterozygous case it's possible
that we'll get
the same conversion from cbga
to cbda or thca but it's also possible
that in the heterozygous case
the enzyme wouldn't be expressed at high
enough levels to fully convert
the cbga to cbda or thca
and in that case we would expect to see
an intermediate value
we currently have a few f1s growing in
the field
between chemotype 3 and chemotype 4
and we'll be testing those once they
start to flower
but at the moment we don't have any hard
data
so there's probably going to be some
variation there is a significant amount
of variation
in um cbda synthase enzymes
we would expect some to be more active
than others
so uh in short it probably varies and
we're working to figure that out
great yeah we should again qualify that
much of the results that were presented
today are mid-season results we have not
analyzed any of the cannabinoids uh from
the 12 cvg lines that were
uh that we have in trials so stay tuned
uh i'm going to point to jamie there's
an excellent question about
pollination and how do we maintain these
uh feminized cbd trials at the same time
we're also doing
uh grain and fiber trials so jamie you
touched on that in the chat box but
let's elaborate on that
okay so um here in in ithaca
our our terrain is very
full of hills and gorges and
and you know very different landscapes
that way
and so we by mileage we keep all of our
trials at least
one mile apart but then in addition to
that they're definitely
separated by lots of landscape features
so our cbd and essential oil trials are
on an area
that's pretty much surrounded by by
forested areas to
sort of as an additional barrier to try
and keep
the pollen out of those areas
and there's another set of questions in
there about
irrigation so did we irrigate through
the drought
and how was fertilization done so this
is one of the major differences between
our current cbd cultivation practices
which are based on plastic culture
and drip irrigation versus the broad
acre
uh grain and fiber cultivation so you
want to talk about that a little bit
jamie
sure so none of our fiber and grain
trials
were irrigated we
did our very best guess on when to plant
based on the weather forecast and what
we could see
but we did not because i have to be
separated by so far
by such a great distance a lot of the
areas where we would plant our grain and
fiber trials are not necessarily in
spots where we even could
irrigate if we wanted to um
so the grain trials are all the fields
are fertilized before
we plant with um i believe this year we
used 2299
it was our fertilizer so it was
broadcast on the fields
at a rate about 75 pounds of nitrogen
per acre
and then at at about
a month into the planting the fiber
trials and the grain trials were given
an additional
70 pounds of nitrogen per acre as
ammonium sulfate
the cbd trials i mean uh
craig is there he could probably talk
more about those those were all through
the
drip irrigation
yep so we've been injecting a
water-soluble fertilizer
we did include granular fertilizer as we
laid the beds uh at about 90 pounds of
nitrogen to the acre
and then we have supplemented that with
soluble uh 12-5-16 fertilizer
through the drip line we've done that
twice in our cbd trials
at this point most of those cbd plants
are in flower or very close to flower
so we will not add any additional
fertilizer at this point
uh although there's a lot of research
that needs to be done
to clarify a best practice here
an optimum management practice but
our plants are quite large right now and
encouraging additional vegetative growth
uh may not be beneficial
overall at this point so many other good
questions in here and we're going to do
our best to answer them
uh if we can't answer them uh in this
q a session by all means follow up with
us
afterwards or follow up with your local
cornell cooperative extension specialist
there's a question about why sending the
chinese
fiber plants to florida was there not
supplemental lighting in the greenhouse
what's going on here jacob do you want
to
answer that question about uh critical
day length
of chinese these chinese varieties
versus
other grain and fiber types for example
so there's a lot that we don't know
about these plants um
we've run some uh gbs on them and uh
craig has some interesting data about
them and
they tend to be quite genetically
distinct
and quite genetically distinct
especially from other grain and
fiber types uh so what we think is going
on
is that it requires a very short day
length
we don't know what that critical photo
period is for a lot of our
full season cbd varieties once the day
length gets below about
14 hours we start seeing flowering for
these plants it might be considerably
lower it might be
13 hours we don't know but in florida
which
is a lot closer to the equator we're
expecting the day
length to be shorter um
and in florida they've the east
collaborator has also been testing
these lines and uh they flowered late in
florida
but they flowered and they were able to
harvest seed in our trials
we didn't push it to the last possible
second um but
we were not able to harvest seed from
these varieties
um and we think it's due to a very
short photo period uh
requirement for these plants to flower
um
so in the greenhouse
uh the plants were mature around march
or so
and at that point uh some of the plants
were just starting to flower
but we don't have a shade curtain and
the daylights were starting to get too
long at that point
and then the plants that were starting
to flower ceased flowering went back to
vegetative
so ultimately if we had a shade curtain
and could block out the sun
we might have been able to get them to
flower but we don't have that facility
yet
yep so the problem was actually not
supplemental lighting
but our lack of ability to
uh deprive the plants to shade the
plants
and keep them dark so we're very much
looking forward to having that light
deprivation shading
so that we can control flowering all 12
months of the year
even when the days are get too long
which is in
march and april uh
some other questions there's a good
question from paul about whether
molecular breeding can be used for pest
and disease resistance
uh that is a great lead-in to our next
talks uh in the next session
uh starting at 10 o'clock
where chris and ali will talk about uh
some of our work
on powdery mildew resistance so yes we
are confident that
we will be able to develop molecular
markers
for at least for some disease resistance
uh other questions or questions about
uh recommendations for the best
cultivars
uh for dual purpose and uh
let me also get back to a question about
a dual purpose
fiber and cbd cultivars so
we have posted our grain and fiber trial
results on our website so please look
those over
i will say there is variability in
the quality of seed lots from year to
year still
that is still a major issue in the
industry
is the ability to get reliably high
quality
seed from year to year finding
a local seed source helps with that so
we have had very good relationship
with uni seeds just across the border in
ontario
in providing us high quality seed
but please please look over those
results
and recognize that they are still only
on a relatively small number of sites
and soil types in new york state i'll
just say in general that
hemp demands the highest quality soils
you have in your farm it requires a deep
rich loam that is well drained so
don't believe the height that hemp can
grow on marginal soils
or as one of my good friends and
colleagues said
you can grow it on marginal soil and
you'll get marginal yield
so it's a good question about producing
cbd
and fiber uh so the cbd
is produced in the female flowers and
to get the optimum fiber long quali uh
high quality long fiber you need to
harvest relatively early right at the
start of flowering
but there may well be enough cbd
produced in those flowers at that point
in the development
that you can get a reasonable yield of
cbd
as well as your yield of high quality
fiber
and hemp flax has produced
a harvester that has a flower harvesting
combine head that can
rise quite high and chop those flower
heads
and at the same time be chopping the
fiber
so we look forward to the
industry continue continuing to expand
and develop that machinery
so that we can potentially do a dual
purpose
uh cbd and fiber harvest and i'll just
answer one more question in here that i
noticed
what about going to a broad acre
cultivation for cbd
that's definitely a trend that we're
seeing in the industry
we're seeing in colorado uh center pivot
irrigation and broad acre
planting uh for cbd we actually have
two trials uh planted this year uh
direct seeded
uh cbd trials one at very high density
similar to our grain and fiber trials
and the other a little bit lower
planted on 30 inch spacing that we
thinned down to
12 or 18 inches between plants
so we have a flower combine header
on order it should come in in a couple
of weeks and that's what we look forward
to
researching next year the end of this
year and next year
is focusing more on broad acre
plantings and combine harvesting of
flower heads for cbd
so i am going to pause right here and we
have a five-minute break
so continue to ask your questions in the
chat box so the panelists can respond to
that
and we will be back and start our
program again
at 10 o'clock thank you everyone
okay welcome back everyone uh it's ten
o'clock
and we're going to resume our program
next on our program well we're starting
our second session
on hemp crop management uh
with some of our pathologists and
entomologists and weed scientists in
this group
starting with a live presentation from
graduate student
ali khaled in the field with chris smart
so chris you're muted you can go ahead
and unmute
and we will start the presentation
okay hi um like larry said my name's ali
ali kayla i'm a graduate student in
chris smart's lab
who is out here with me um of course
we're staying six feet apart
and also out here is um another lab
member of ours collin day
um so sorry in advance if we uh
disconnect we're we're gonna do our best
but
um i just wanted to talk a little bit
about some of my research
so i'm looking mostly at a pathogen
called
powdery mildew which we have out here
in the field that we wanted to show you
and
we are working with larry's lab to do
some um
looking for resistance for powdery
mildew but i wanted to talk a little bit
about a different project today
um about how pottery mildew can affect
secondary metabolites
in hemp so we all know about
some secondary metabolites like
cannabinoids like
which include cbd and cpg
but there's another class of secondary
metabolites that hemp
produces a lot of which are terpenes
and terpenes are a volatile or volatile
compounds that are
also produced by the flower and are
responsible for
the um fragrance and flavor of
the hemp flowers so
we have um three
major questions that we're trying to
address with this project
the first being how can how do the
terpene
profiles in hemp change throughout
the season and how does flowering time
affect
those terpene profiles and so for that
project
we are collecting terpene samples weekly
throughout the season
from same plants
and so our second question is how do
how does a biological fungicide
affect the terpene profiles
and for that project we have
been treating some plants with a
bacillus based biological fungicide
according to the label rate and we've
taken samples from
a from plants that were treated and
plants that were untreated
and i recently inoculated those plants
with powdery mildew
and once infection is established we'll
take another collection from those
plants and we'll be able to see
how those compare and then the third
question is more relating to
the pathogens themselves and how the
pathogens
can affect terpene profiles as well as
cannabinoid profiles
um and for that one we're adding in a
second pathogen botrytis gray mold
so we will have plants inoculated with
powdery mildew
plants inoculated with botrytis and
healthy plants
and we'll take terpene samples from all
three of those
types of plants and see how the terpene
levels differ
um and for the that um for that project
as well at the end of the season we will
also take um flower samples so that we
can look at cannabinoid profiles as well
so for collecting terpenes it's a little
bit
um more challenging and we have to get a
little bit more creative since those
compounds
are volatiles so we have kind of an
interesting setup for
our collections that we kind of wanted
to talk about and show you today
so we have our setup here and we use
these turkey bags they're just
these plastic bags that you people use
to cook turkeys
in so we i actually have to bake these
so that we don't have to
um have any interference with chemicals
from the bags and what we're collecting
and we take these bags and we just
secure them around a part of the plant
that we want to collect usually a part
that has flowers
we secure it at the base with some zip
ties to make it
um nice and secure and then
from there we cut two holes in the bag
one so we have air flow in
and one so we have airflow out for the
hole that is the airflow in we secure
a filter so that the air coming in isn't
going to contaminate our sample
and then for the airflow out we have
um it's connected to some tubing which
is then
connected to a collection tube which has
a filter inside
that the compounds can stick to
then the collection tube is connected to
a pump
which provides the airflow and all of
this
equipment is provided to us by
dennis willett's lab who we're
collaborating with on this project
and once we have our
collection on this tube it goes directly
onto a machine called a gas
uh spec gas spectrometer and mess
guess chromatomatographs
sorry and mass spectrometer um
and that machine can allow us to see
what compounds are there
and at what levels they're there so we
can determine
a secondary metabolite profile for all
of our samples and
the gcms is also provided by
the dennis willett lab who is working
with us on this project and they're
kindly letting us use
all of this equipment um so
that is what i've got for my secondary
metabolite project
oh yes and um we have some more
powdery on this plant that's part of the
reason we're out in this
trial we have some nice examples of
powdery
out here
so um i'm looking forward to answering
any questions later during the
q a session
uh back back to larry okay
that's great thank you thanks very much
uh that worked great
uh and uh folks can definitely see
that uh we have our share of powdery
mildew
in our trials uh and i'm going to shift
now to start presentation from jen starr
in gary bergstrom's lab and she will
give you some excellent descriptions of
other diseases
uh we have had in him
hello and welcome to the 2020 virtual
cornell hemp research
team field day my name is jennifer starr
and i am the research support specialist
for dr gary bergstrom's field crops
pathology laboratory
i also work alongside kevin myers who
helps with scouting for hemp disease and
does our molecular testing
today i'll be giving a brief overview of
foliar diseases and possible
management strategies i want to focus
this talk on just a few things
to highlight i will start with septoria
leaf spot
and bi polaris leaf spot also known as
hemp leaf spot
then i will move to lesser impact
emerging leaf diseases
such as downy mildew and hemp rust
septorial leaf spot is caused by the
fungus septoria species
and symptoms begin on the lower leaves
of the plant
as irregularly shaped spots with yellow
margins
these spots expand over time turn brown
and the yellow margins brought in to
look something like this
this was observed in eastern new york in
2019
and in eastern and western new york in
2020
in this slide i have a video of what
septorial leaf spot looks like in the
fields
and as you can see it is on the lower
level
spots with the bigger yellow margins
this is septoria leaf spot
the next highlight is bipolaris leaf
spot also known as hemp leaf spot
this is caused by a fungus that's being
classified as bipolaris gigantia
related to dreschlera gigantea
symptoms start as round specs and spots
that coalesce over time
and sometimes they have a dark margin
here with lighter tan interiors or
sometimes don't have
any margin at all we have noticed this
leaf spot disease since cornell's hemp
team
started the program a few years back and
we usually notice this
at the end of the growing season and
we've noticed throughout new york state
this is not a super high impact
disease as other states have seen it
defoliate plants we have not seen that
yet
in new york state
next up we have downy mildew
lesser impact emerging disease
this is caused by pseudopornosphera
which has just been recently id'd by
sequencing
last week the spots start out as these
light green
yellow spots with necrotic margins and
the lower surface of the leaf you can
actually see the fungus growing in humid
conditions
or if you catch it in the morning time
when the dew is still
on the plant later on
the lesions become a little more angular
and are defined
by the leaf veins of the hemp plant
this was just recently observed in
ithaca last week
so in 2020
and in the next slide i have a video of
what it looks like on
the plant
and this is a good example of how
the veins of the leaf are demarcating
the spot
and confining it as you see here
this is downy mildew on hemp
our last feature is hemp rust
and hemp rust has been morphologically
identified as urido cregariana
and again this is something we're going
to want to be looking on the lower
surface of the leaf
we have yellow to orange pustules or
spots on the lower surface
and on the upper surface we have these
necrotic areas with very faint chlorosis
around them
and then sometimes rust disease systems
have alternate hosts to complete their
life cycle
we have not found an alternate host with
this hemp rust
sometimes breast disease systems don't
have alternate hosts
we found this last year at the end of
the growing season in october of 2019
we will be looking again this year
for this so we can try to study it
further
the following slide is a close-up of
what the pustule looks like
on the under surface of the leaf and
what is inside that pustule
these are uradiniospores of hemp rust
we do see other hemp leaf spots
i wanted to include a quick
summary of those here
we see crystal ariella zone 8 leaf spot
we see a circular
leaf spot we see some philium leaf spot
and we also see a number of other
diseases that are not leaf spots
we see fusarium bud light which could
have
implications for quality of flowers and
grain
we see fusarium wilt we see white molds
and we see botrytis gray mold so as you
can see in addition to leaf spot
diseases we do see
and work on other diseases that are
affecting hemp
so possible product treatments we are
directing
growers to go to the dec
new york dec web page if this address
and go to pesticide product information
hit search
this will bring you to advanced search
you want to click
that press search which will then bring
you
to pesticide use you want to choose hemp
industrial hit search that will bring up
about 98 products most of which
are biologic in nature some bacillus
type products
you want to check the labels on those to
make sure hemp is included
all of this information again is present
on the cornell hemp webpage
under the faq heading
in addition to the dec web page we want
to use best agronomic practices
this will be second nature to seasoned
growers and producers
but we want to start with prevention
with having reliable seed source and
good soil health
it is a myth that hemp can be produced
on marginal soils
we want fertile soil well-drained soil
we want our plant spacing to be
such where we're reducing the humidity
between the plants
because fungus really loves
to be in humid places it encourages its
growth
sanitation very important we want to
remove debris
off site you may burn it you may compost
it but we want it away from the hemp
field weed control also very important
we have noticed cercasper growing on
weeds we have noticed
downy mildew growing on weeds are those
weeds vectors
for fungal growth to the hemp or is it
the other way around we are still
investigating that
but it's important to keep those weeds
in control and out of the way
crop rotation also something to note um
edible beans soy beans sunflowers
and they're white molds probably not a
great idea to
follow hemp after those crops also
in question recently corn and cereal
crops
producing mycotoxins will be wise to put
hemp after those crops and then
resistant cultivars
something that our program here at
cornell are working towards now
if you have questions about your hemp
crop
and have problems and want some
diagnostics
it may be wise for you to contact your
cornell cooperative extension
educator if you don't know who yours is
you may go
to the cornell hemp page
and find who your representative is
if you would like to submit samples to
my lab you may submit them through your
cornell cooperative extension educator
through them to us we may not give you
the best turnaround time
but it will be of no charge to you or if
you're looking for some quick results
you can use
our plant disease diagnostic clinic at
cornell
and it is a fee for service it's
relatively low cost i believe it's
thirty to thirty five dollars if you're
in state fifty dollars if you're out of
state and i've left
the contact information for you here
again all of this information
is on the cornell team web page
i'm going to leave you with our lab's
contact information
this is dr gary bergstrom's email
address
this is my email address and our
laboratory phone number
if you have further questions after this
talk today
thanks for your time and i hope you
enjoy the rest of
cornell's virtual hemp talks today
thanks very much jen we're a little bit
ahead of schedule now
uh we have a couple of minutes for
questions
uh so i do see a couple of questions in
the chat box
if jenn or gary are available and want
to follow up on those questions one
is are any of these products
omri listed
i'll just jump in this gary uh there are
quite a few
things lusted with uh fungicidal or
insecticidal activity on the omri list
and a lot of those are on the dec
list the term suggested
is is uh problematic because there's
very there's very little uh test data
uh supporting efficacy at this point and
i know that uh
that chris and her lab is looking at
that in the context of mildew and
whatnot
we we've done some fairly rudimentary
testing
uh for some of the late season things
but really there's not
there's not a database there to uh to
point to
so we have counseled growers uh to
look at uh a few materials that have
uh efficacy in other crop areas
um so we have some insights that they
might work and and to try to
to do some treated strips and leave some
non-treated to try to learn
something here but uh recommendations
are are a bit elusive
at least for us in new york at this
point
there's another question specifically
about uh
bacillus fungicides uh cease or
serenade i don't know if chris has
included those in her
trial i see chris is on uh or
but but again the trial is underway we
don't have results
at this point as gary mentioned uh it's
definitely an
active area of research uh
jan and gary one more question before we
move on to marion's presentation uh from
nicole
de city cultivar differences in
susceptibility to leaf spots
great question to call and i know you're
interested in this as well and
and uh the answer is hopeful yes we
whether they're repeatable differences
that's what we want to know
we have particular opportunity uh in the
cultivar trials out
out this year uh to try to discriminate
uh varieties in the cultivars in the
sense of
downy mildew for sure and and also uh
i i think with the helmet the sport with
the uh by polaris hemp leaf spot as well
but yeah that's a goal and we're not
there yet uh
perhaps in kentucky you got a better
read on some of that
thanks yep thanks very much gary and jen
great presentation
we are going to move on i'm going to
start uh marion zuffle's presentation
from new york state ipm
i will just give you a heads up the
audio
is uh the audio levels on this video
are pretty low uh so you may need to
turn up your volume a bit
uh once it gets started here
good morning my name is marion zuffali
and i work for the new york state
integrated pest management program
today i'm going to talk to you about
insect pests or potential insect pests
of hemp
and their management this was my first
summer working in hemp and i've really
enjoyed the experience
so my goal this summer was to just go
out there
and learn as much as i can about hemp
try to identify any insects and diseases
that are out there
so today i'm going to specifically just
talk about the insect pests we've
already heard about some of the diseases
out there
so i'm just going to focus in on what
insects i found
before i get started i first just wanted
to stress the importance of scouting and
identification because not everything
that's out there is a pest
in fact very few insects to date have
caused enough damage to impact hemp
and this crop is still relatively new so
we don't have a lot of thresholds for
any insect pests that we do find
so for this reason it's very important
for you to go out scout your hemp fields
regularly
and that way you can notice any
potential problems and keep an eye on
them
so what i did this summer was i scouted
nine different hemp fields
weekly as well as one high tunnel and i
also set up uh european corn borer
tracks which you can see here in the
picture
next to hempfield so i can monitor the
flight of european corn borer which is
one of the known pests
potential pests of hemp again not
everything is a pest so we have to be
able to identify
what's a pest what's a beneficial and
what's an incidental an insect is
that just happens to be out in the field
but isn't causing any damage
okay so now i'm going to go over some of
the insects that i did find this season
the first one that i encountered was
early in the season while the plants
were still in the greenhouse
the grower came to me and he informed me
that hundreds of the seedlings were
dying
and you can see that from the top um
upper right hand corner
the seedlings were turning yellow and
were dying and he wasn't quite sure what
was causing it
and we noticed that he had a lot of
fungus gnats and he also had fusarium
and we determined that it was fucerum we
took some seedlings and sent them to
chris smart and she identified fusarium
in the seedlings
so the fungus gnats they are tiny little
flies that lay their eggs
in wet soil near the base of the plants
the larvae will
hatch out of the eggs and then they
start feeding on decaying matter but
they will also feed on roots
and both the adult fungus gnats as well
as the larvae can transmit diseases such
as fusarium
so what the grower did is he changed out
his potting media and then he also
decreased his watering he was
over watering his plants and you're
supposed to really let them dry out
between waterings let the top layer dry
out between waterings
and that really helped his um fungus net
problem
and he also introduced nematodes so one
thing you can do to monitor for fungus
gnats is you can place yellow sticky
cards in your greenhouse
so that you can detect them early if you
do have fungus gnats
you should allow this top layer of soil
to dry out completely this will
kill both the fungus as well as which
the nets feed on as well as the fungus
net larvae so really let that soil dry
out between waterings
this is the two spotted spider mite
these are small little mites found on
the underside of leaves and they cause
this stippling appearance that you can
see in both of the pictures kind of on
the upper surface of the leaves you
usually notice the stippling first and
then if you turn the leaf over you'll
find the
spider mites these i found in the high
tunnel
as well as in the field and both of them
both in the high tunnel as well as
in the field the numbers stayed fairly
low the high tunnel has since been
harvested
and no control measures were needed and
the populations in the field have never
increased i
monitor it weekly and the numbers have
stayed very very low
two spotted spider mites do prefer very
hot dry weather
so one of the ways to manage for them is
to make sure that your plants aren't
water stressed
you can also remove any potential weed
hosts that are surrounding your field
and then if you do have a spider mite
problem or you know that you will
you can release predatory mites to
control the spread of my population
but if you do do this you have to do it
in advance of
the spider mites becoming out of control
so as soon as you have that first sign
of two spotted spider mites you want to
release your beneficial predatory mites
this is the red-headed flea beetle which
was probably the most numerous insect
that i observed this summer
the adults are fairly large three to six
millimeters and have a reddish brown
head and a shiny black body
they feed on the leaves between the
between the veins and
cause these holes all over the leaves
even though they were very numerous and
i saw quite a bit of damage all the
plants grow out of it
and the young seedlings are the ones
that are most at risk from flea beetle
damage
so some of the control measures you can
do is you can protect your young
seedlings with row cover until they're
large enough to withstand the feeding
pressure
you can also plow in the to decrease the
overwintering population
and then you can use beneficial
nematodes which will control the larvae
in the soil
i also found some aphids these are small
sap sucking insects kind of pear-shaped
they're found on the underside of the
leaves but they can also be found near
the stem
or in the flowers there are several
different species
of aphids that are known to occur on
hemp of the nine fields that i was
scouting only one of them did i find
aphids in and they remained on the lower
leaves
and there was a lot of beneficials
including ladybugs and my new pirate
bugs
and lace wings that really kept the
population under control
they are still out there and i'm still
monitoring them weekly
to make sure the population doesn't get
any bigger
i did take a sample and i sent it to the
cornell insect diagnostic lab
for identification because i don't know
what species it is
but i only found the one in one field
there are a few different insects that
were born into the stem of hemp
including the common stock bore which is
pictured here as well as european corn
borer and the hemp ore the only one that
i found this
season was the common stock for i've not
found the other ones
i did set up traps for european corn
borer but the numbers were very very low
and i never found any in the plant
so here's a picture of a larvae inside a
hemp stock
they are brown with these long white
lines that run the length of the body
the female will lay her eggs in grasses
and weeds kind of around the edge of a
field and when they hatch the when the
larvae hatch
they will move into the field looking
for a suitable plant to bore into
so one of the management options is to
control your weeds and grasses
in the surrounding fields usually if you
do have stock bore it's going to be
on the edge of fields where you're going
to find the damage
another option is to plant your plants
early so that they're large enough that
when
the larvae move in they can withstand
some of that boring damage
chemical control options are limited
because once they're inside the stem
they're protected from any kind of
chemical control
this is the last insect that i'm going
to talk about the yellow woolly bear
caterpillar
this is a caterpillar that feeds on many
different plants including hemp
it's covered in yet dense yellow hairs
over its entire body
and this one i found in the high tunnel
that i was scouting and usually it
doesn't cause a problem the female lays
about 50 eggs on a host plant
and the caterpillars they feed together
for a little while but then they
disperse throughout the field
and just cause a little bit of damage to
individual plants
but because this was in a high tunnel
they were all concentrated in one
area and they couldn't disperse it
caused much more significant damage
so when i was in their scouting i
noticed a lot of the plants the lower
third
of the plant was completely defoliated
so i notified the grower about that
and what we ended up doing he just went
in and hand-picked them all
there's probably about a hundred or so
in the high tunnel but he could control
them since it wasn't a defined area he
could just go in
and hand pick them all to remove them
and it didn't really cause any
serious damage because we were able to
get rid of them
so here just real briefly is a list of
some of the other insects that i found
on him which includes the leaf miner
which i'm attempting to rear out to
determine what kind of what species it
is
four line plant bug various caterpillars
different grasshoppers brown marmorated
stink bug
leaf hoppers tree hoppers um the oblique
banded leaf roller i was able to rear
that out
um and the tarnished plant bug so as you
can see there's a lot of different
insects that are found on hemp
not all of them are pests so it's
important to know what's a pest which
just what's
an incidental and of course as i
mentioned before what are your
beneficials so that you can
just control the ones that you need to
so if there's any questions
i will take those now okay thank you
marion
uh marian is on so
i see a couple of questions in the chat
we have one minute here
uh if you want to pick one out
uh
[Music]
there's a question about uh how
prevalent corn borers have been in
cornfields
in new york and uh will this corn borer
population potentially impact hemp
sorry you can hear me yep okay good um
so european corn borer in general has
been very low in the state
for at least 10 15 years now
after the introduction of bt pilcorn
we do think it might start increasing
there's more non-gmo field
being grown so the european corn border
population might increase
what impact european corn borer is going
to have on hemp i don't know we haven't
i have
personally not seen any corn borer on
hemp um
i think hemp it doesn't tend to lodge or
break as easily as corn does so it might
not if when the corn bore gets
inside the hem plant it might not have
as much of an impact on the hemp
itself um but having not seen it i
i couldn't say for sure and
one maybe one other question here
there's a question about
uh beneficial control
of two spotted spider mites predatory
mites versus ladybugs do you have any uh
data on that i don't have any data i
know that
i've worked with two spotted spider
mites in other crops
and the predatory mites do a great job
i've
never intentionally released ladybugs
specifically for
spider mite control more so for afic
control so i don't know how well the
ladybugs would do on
spider mites specifically i i do know
that predatory mites do well but i don't
have any data on the ladybugs
okay great thanks marianne uh we are
going to move on
uh to lynn sosnoski's talk here
hello so let me get that cued up
oh welcome to my talk about weeds and
weed management
and hemp my name is lynn sisnoski and
i'm an assistant professor
of weed biology ecology and management
and specialty crops here at cornell
university
weeds in any cropping system compete
with the crop for water
nutrients and light and that can
directly impact
yield quantity and quality
weeds that become established in crops
can alter the microclimates around the
plants which can then impact disease
development
and weeds can actually serve as
alternate hosts for both
pests and pathogens in car cropping
systems
vegetation that isn't controlled can
reduce the final harvestability of the
crop
and the absence of any kind of
vegetation control
chemicals in the hemp crop itself may
necessitate the use of multiple
and integrated practices to suppress
weeds that become established
with respect to integrated weed
management and hemp
the first step should always be proper
site selection
and that means avoiding fields with
perennials or extremely high weed
densities
if you're going to start clean make sure
to try and stay clean
always manage and harvest your cleanest
fields
first with respect to planting date
you might be able to plant and get ahead
of weeds
for example if the field that you're
planting into has a
lot of summer emerging weed species
choose an earlier planting date that
allows your crop to get up
and gives it some kind of competitive
advantage
against the vegetation it's going to be
competing with
using a stale seed bed technique where
you stimulate the germination
of weeds and then eliminate emerged
ceilings both physically
and chemically can be a really useful
tool
but understand that not all weeds are
going to respond equally well
species with non-dormant seeds might be
better controlled under this strategy as
opposed to species with dormant seeds
make sure that you have the best
planting conditions that you can achieve
for instance making sure you have a nice
even seed bed
so that you have good soil to seed
contact for even germination
which will improve the crops competitive
ability
make sure that you plant with
appropriate densities to minimize that
open space that weeds can then colonize
if you're using transplants this can be
a really useful strategy to give your
crop a competitive size advantage over
the weeds
choosing varieties can have an influence
on how competitive the crop
is as well based on the heights and the
branching traits that that
varieties possesses if you're going to
be cultivating make sure you keep your
rows
as straight as possible to maximize
cultivation performance
and get the weeds while they are small
either at the white thread or the early
seedling
stages if you're using plastic mulch
remember that this is still going to
require weeding between beds
and removing weeds that emerge through
the planting holes
so even though herbicides aren't
available for use in hemp directly
they're
likely to be used in crops that are
planted before him
and we have to pay attention to this
because these products have rotation
restrictions
on the label and hemp may not be
explicitly listed but the term
other crop often is and hemp is going to
fall
into that other crop category
so if you're interested in understanding
the type of plant back restrictions that
might be encountered in industrial hemp
production i suggest doing a google
search for the terms wisconsin
hemp and rotation restrictions and
you're really likely to find
this nice handout that was produced by
uw madison
which explicitly looks at the
restrictions
that are associated with the herbicides
that are used in
pre-seeding crops
these are some of the rotation
restrictions that my colleagues at
uw-madison
found across multiple herbicide labels
and you can see they're extremely
varied in the amount of time that you
need to wait before you can plant
industrial hemp for example for the
fuselage and select max labels there was
a one-month rotation restriction
for something like pursuit in miss
appear
there was a 40-month rotation
restriction
now understand the list is not inclusive
and labels can and do
change and it is your responsibility to
always consult the labels
before making any herbicide application
and before planting crops
following herbicide applications
just because we don't have herbicides
currently labeled for use in hemp
doesn't mean that we aren't looking to
see how herbicides
affect him we have a lot of herbicide
trials that are currently
underway in the united states and
they're being undertaken
for multiple reasons the first of which
is to
identify active ingredients that will be
safe to use
in hemp and to address pest management
needs in the u.s hemp
industry the second reason is to
identify herbicides that will be able to
control
hemp escapes that occur in following
crops
and the third reason is to characterize
herbicide symptomology
in the case of herbicide carryover or
drift
injury while there's considerable
interest in conducting hemp herbicide
trials
very few have actually made it to formal
publication
stage yet the one exception being some
work that's been recently undertaken by
michael flesner's group
at virginia tech university and this is
a really good paper
where they evaluated herbicide tolerance
of industrial hemp
in both greenhouse and field conditions
so the objective of the research that
was conducted in michael flesner's lab
was to test
hep tolerance to both pre-emergence and
post-emergence herbicides
and when we say pre-emergence herbicides
we're talking soil applied herbicides
and when we're talking we're talking
fully or applied herbicides
they did conduct this across years and
they did do the studies in both
greenhouse and in
field trials and what they saw was
variability across
time and between growing conditions
although with respect to the results
they did find that esmetolochlor
was the least injurious of the soil
applied herbicides
in the field although their greenhouse
trials did suggest that other active
ingredients may have potential for
future research
with respect to the foliar applied
herbicides
quizalifop and cythoxadim which are both
grass herbicides
were found to be the least injurious of
the post products
along with clopirolid and bromoxinil
i'd like you to know that we're also
conducting herbicide trials
here at cornell agritech these are the
results from
a preliminary screening project that
we've started to look at the
safety of post-emergence or foliar
applied herbicides and industrial hemp
and you can see that our results largely
agree with those that were
achieved by michael flechner's group
primarily if we're looking at percent
injury
the post-emergence herbicides currently
in our trial providing the least amount
of
injury to hemp are clethodyn which is a
wssa1 herbicide
clopyramid and bromoximil
so we plan to continue these herbicide
screens both
in the greenhouse and under field
conditions this fall
and in 2021 the previous slide showed
you
our post-emergence herbicides that we're
looking at we also have a suite of
pre-emergence herbicides that we'll be
evaluating
and again we'll be doing it in both the
greenhouse and field conditions
we hope to have some trials describing
the impacts of herbicide carry over and
drift
on crop growth and yield development
we're also hoping to look at the biology
of hemp and evaluate its competitiveness
with both
current weed issues such as velvet leaf
foxtail
find weed and nightshade and
up-and-coming problems in new york such
as palmer amaranth and waterhemp
i'd like to thank you very much for
attending today's talk
if you'd like to get in touch with me to
discuss weeds in weed management
in hemp or in any specialty crops
feel free to contact me via email at
lms438
cornell.edu on my office phone
at 315-787-2231
if you're on social media you can find
me on both twitter
and instagram again thank you so much
for coming and attending my talk
i'll be present during the break if you
have any questions
and have a good rest of your day
okay thanks very much lynn uh we now
have time for our q and a session
uh for about 15 minutes and then we'll
take another five minute break
uh so i've seen if uh our panelists here
could unmute that would be great
and uh i'll try to pick out some of the
questions from the chat
there were some questions about uh
seeing leaf hoppers on hemp and gypsy
moth on hemp
uh mary do you want to comment on the
potential impact of
i think joe meant potato leaf hoppers
yeah so i i did find some potato leaf
hoppers
um oh it's i don't remember exactly when
probably at least
six seven weeks ago now um a lot of
adults
they came in i was concerned and within
two weeks they were all gone and they
did not reproduce
now i did hear from others that they
have caused problems in the fields i
were in
they never reproduced and it's mainly
the nymphs that are that cause the
hopper burn and
a lot of the feeding damage so i did not
experience that um
i don't know if other people have had
issues with with leaf hopper but not
that i'm aware of
and for the gypsy moth those were in the
high tunnel i found
i think about two or three i don't know
if it's
actually a problem it happened to be
there um
i don't know if they how extensively
they were feeding they probably nibbled
a little bit um
i don't think that gypsy moth is going
to be a pest it's just
one of those things that i found so i
put it in the other insects i found
category so one thing i if i have a
minute just to mention one thing real
quickly i said that i found some aphids
on hemp
and i sent them to the diagnostic lab so
i received um verification that they are
cannabis aphids which
is the first verification in new york so
we have it here
um just so everybody's aware of
yeah we had a lot of vapids last year at
the end of the season
did you get it did you find out what
they were
uh i thought we did have them
confirmed as cannabis oh you did okay
okay elsa
told me that was for as far as he knew
his first verification
but okay uh let me just point it to
jamie because
uh again in the vines lab they have a
lot of experience working with
potato leafhopper and hopper burn on
alfalfa
and i know jamie if she's still on
has seen some hopper burn on hemp
in ithaca but she may not be on right
now
larry i can talk about that i i was in
the the ithaca fiber and grain plots
um i think last
week it might have been the week before
and there's considerable
damage from potato leaf hopper on both
on all on grain dual and
fiber and it is quite striking and
remarkable
i am not an entomologist or insect
person so i don't know what
stage these insects are um but it
is occurring and
striking i will say that so i i don't
know if they have good years and bad
years but
this was definitely a good year for
potato leaf hopper
on hemp in ithaca yeah yeah
uh going back to some of the earlier
questions uh
to ally and chris uh folks were asking
about
uh whether we're asking both the
volatile
terpenes and uh the non-volatile
terpenes so unfortunately we haven't
had the bandwidth to do as much detailed
work on the terpenes as we would like
but
uh ali and chris where do we stand on
characterization of all the different
types of terpenes
um so we're right now just looking at
volatile terpenes um
that's what we have standards for
and um anything that's not a volatile
were
our cannabinoids
generally so yeah
right so um i think at the end of the
season
we'll um take flowers and get
um total cannabinoid analysis and we'll
be working with dennis to try to get
a broader panel of terpenes as well
great uh there's a question uh from
jeff kostya to lin any work on ethyl
floralin
for pre-plant application and hemp has
minor use approval in canada
yeah and i i just sent a a written
response to that
so uh yes there there are there is some
work that is being done
in the u.s in various labs looking at
ethyl floralin as well as the other
dinitro aniline
herbicides so pendimethalin and
trifluralin
with i don't remember the exact results
with ethyl floral and that i've seen
there has been
varied response and safety uh with
respect to pentamethylene
but pendimethaline ethyl fluorine and
trifluralin are all going to be products
that will be
tested in our pre-emergence herbicide
trials
yeah let me just throw out a question
probably
to everyone and that is uh
what is the potential outcome of using
some of these products
on the test results for cbd extracts
so there is some evidence that hemp can
concentrate
uh some of these compounds and uh
we do know through our interactions with
the folks at pixas international
that some of their hemp crops have
failed
in that final testing so growers
definitely need to
be in contact with their buyer and
understand the standards
for testing that's going to be done in
the final cbd product anyone want to
comment on that
yeah i mean that's exactly right larry
and um
i've actually interacted with now two
different growers here in the state of
new york
um that have gone through quality
control testing
um and had either you know they a
microbial
issue so things are they're tested for
heavy metals
for pesticides and for microbials and
so it is important to to
[Music]
know the final market know what's going
to be tested and then i guess i would
throw it to gary
in terms of grain issues which are
really important as well i don't know
all the answers to the chris
to that question and i think it's super
important as you stated there
we were both on a conference at the
plant pathology
meetings where speakers from canada were
telling us
absolutely nothing was allowed in end
products no
no residues of a biological control no
residues of any kind of chemical
so i don't know if the u.s industry will
be
uh handled that same way but uh it's a
real concern
um we're focused on trying to reduce any
potential from mycotoxins uh which
there's significant uh potential there
um and that takes away a pretty big set
of tools
if we if we can't control things during
the flowering process so
that uh maybe somebody else on the call
has some insights
it's a real question
lynn do you have any insights on
herbicide carryover
herbicide uptake from hemp
yeah that's actually a really good
question and and that is
not a topic i think that any weed
scientist debate has
actually addressed um it's
there was a in fact a lot of the weed
science work hasn't been addressed at
all
to date and there was a actually a paper
put out last year
in 2019 kind of expressly saying how far
behind we are with respect to all of
these questions in the discipline
so there's more that needs to be done
yep and i'll just uh
very briefly try to answer paul's
question about what specific soil
testing would you recommend
pre-planting uh again i
i know we have discussed this with our
colleagues at pixas
uh hemp is particularly good at taking
up cadmium
lead you don't want to plant on a field
that has lead
uh but we really have a lot more work to
do
to characterize uh what heavy metals
you would want to test for and
specifically avoid those fields
implanting cbd hemp there may be other
pesticide residues also that you would
want to
test for but we really don't have a good
handle on that that's a very good
question
uh it's an interesting question here
or comment from raul at rutgers that
uh they've had a substantial population
of stink bugs
in their cbd hemp trial uh
and marion do you want to comment on uh
stink bugs
so i've seen brown marmorated stink bugs
and i found some stink bug
egg masses um i've actually have some
pictures of brown marmorated stink bugs
mating in hemp
um but have not seen a lot of feeding
damage
i mentioned the majority of the feeding
damage i've seen but it's also hard to
distinguish sometimes
feeding damage if i'm not actively
seeing the insect feed
there's a lot of other sucking insects
that could have caused the damage
so i have not personally observed a lot
of stink bugs the only one i've seen is
brown marmorated
and um and a few stink bug egg masses
yeah i was also asked a question about
uh spotted lanternfly
whether hemp might be a host for spotted
lanternfly
uh so far as far as i know in
pennsylvania they have not seen
and and i heard this from melissa
collins at penn state
uh they have not seen any damage to him
from spotted lanternfly
do you have any uh insights on that i
have yeah i
actually have no idea if they would get
onto hemp or not it seems to have a
pretty
broad host range so potentially
but yes i have no idea
here's a question from josh with palmer
amaranth in new york what challenges
might we see in regard to hemp
production and harvest
are hemp harvesters harvesters capable
of doing a good job
so yeah um so
i obviously have not dealt with with
hemp and hemp harvest and and palmer
amaranth but i have worked with palmer
amaranth which is the weed behind me
in almonds actually in california and uh
yeah that's
that that goes back to the
harvestability issue um
you know palmer amaranth gets very large
very quickly
uh it gets lignified and it can stop up
cotton harvesters
and and you know a corn harvester so i
expect that a significant population
will
impede the harvestability of hemp as
well
yep i'll just comment that uh again for
high quality
fiber production fiber hemp production
there is a very very low tolerance for
weeds
so it has been a challenge for us in the
absence of any labeled herbicides
to maintain to establish and maintain a
weed spotless field that would meet
those quality thresholds for
high quality fiber harvest
for those folks who have been looking at
the chat any final questions you want to
address here in our last minute before
the break
um i'm gonna i'm gonna throw there was a
question about crop density
and uh weed control and that falls into
that that last
uh bullet point from my slide of future
research
um that's going to look at the
competitiveness of hemp
with various weed species and crop
density impacts are going to be rolled
into
into that so i don't
there is work that is being done nothing
by other universities nothing has been
published yet but i'll be doing some of
that work here
hopefully in the coming um 2021.
yeah and again we in in cbd hemp at
least we've relied
on uh plastic mulch heavily for weed
management
but as the industry shifts to more broad
acre direct seeded plantings
uh those studies are going to be
critical so it's great to have lynn
on our team there is a question about um
xerotal and powdery mildew and i have um
tested that so xerotal is going to
sanitize whatever it touches
but it will become ineffective very
quickly and so
um uh in in what we have done to date
and we are expanding this but other
products including
bacillus based products and um oil based
products
when applied prior to powdery mildew
getting there
are much more effective than the xero
tall in our studies
great uh just one final uh
comment here there have been a couple of
questions about recommending labs for
testings
uh we are we're not going to recommend a
particular lab we don't have a
validation protocol for validating the
results from different commercial labs
but we do have a listing of potential
labs that you can use
in particular uh ones that can test for
heavy metals and toxins are are kind of
rare they're
relatively few and if you go to our
website we try to maintain
a complete list of lab resources that
you could potentially use
but i won't call them recommendations so
we're going to take a break here it's 10
56.
so another five minute break and we will
be back at 11 o'clock with
our presentation from alan taylor thanks
very much everyone
to uh our panelists
okay it's 1101 we're going to move on to
our third
session here uh
talking about uh supply chains and
regulatory issues
we are going to start with a talk from
alan taylor
on seed treatments and soil-borne
pathogens
my name is alan taylor
professor of seed science and technology
at cornell agritech
my laboratory has been involved in hemp
seed science and technology research
since the cornell hemp team
formed in 2017. what i'm going to speak
about
today is on our work on the research and
development of hemp seed treatments
gary bergstrom is my cooperator in plant
pathology
as his laboratory is supportive
and helping characterize the pathogens
associated with
disease seedlings from our research
plots
we also have phil trials at north dakota
state with burton johnson
and chuck johnson and john fike at
virginia tech
so the focus of our work is on
application technology to begin
with to have good methodology
for seed treatment and coding
technologies this is a laboratory scale
unit called a rotary pan technology an
r6 for a six inch diameter
this same technology is used for
commercial scale equipment
so anything that we do in the laboratory
can quickly be scaled up to a larger
an issue that we had early on is that we
need to ensure that we have a uniformity
of application
over the seed surface and from seed to
seed
we need to protect each seed from attack
of the soil borne pathogens at time of
sowing
we'll take a step back and look at the
biological market as there's a number of
materials
now this is not restricted to seed
treatments these could be foliar
applications
or soil applications and furrow
applications we have bio fertilizers and
biostimulants which we're not going to
be talking about
even though my laboratory is working
with biostimulant seed treatments
we're going to focus on biological
control products
in particular the bio pesticides so
we're going to kind of focus in on that
area
so under the bio pesticides we have
biochemicals
they may be kind of a mineral based they
can be either
formed from copper or phosphites we have
examples of those
microbials we normally think of a
microbial as a biopesticide
but they're not the only materials but
in this case
we are using specific seed treatments of
from bacillus and trichoderma
and with others and these are commercial
formulations
that we are testing on as seed
treatments
so this is our list of 12 seed
treatments that we have those in green
are the biologicals
first thing we have to do is test the
seed treatment
application rate we want to ensure that
there's no phytotoxicity
from the seed treatments those in red
are the biochemicals
safeguard is an organic copper the
prudent is a phosphite material
and then the group at the bottom in blue
apron xl maxim you probably recognize
as these are widely labeled on
vegetables
and field crops for as seed treatments
so first let's look at what happens
to seeds after they're planted we start
off here in the laboratory to look at
hemp seeds germinate very rapidly so in
this pathogen-infested soil that we have
the soil
sprinkled over on top during the
germination process
after four days the seeds germinate very
rapidly
after seven days many of the seedlings
have died or are dying
and by 10 days non-treated seeds
are killed so this is a way that we can
use
a laboratory screening method taking
advantage of a naturally pathogenic
pathogen-infested soil to go ahead and
to test these
seed treatments before we actually go to
the field
but our primary interest in showing you
today
is the field data this is our two we
have two stick
field studies at cornell the first one
planted in june 12.
again now we can see how this color
coding is going to help us the black bar
on the left is the control non-treated
you see all the green treatments none of
the biological is doing any better than
the control
however the safeguard the organic copper
the the prudent the phosphite doing
quite well and as good as
one of our best apron maxim treatments
so this looks very promising we have a
second study
also in ithaca this year planted on june
26th
again the same trend is the biologicals
not performing any better than the
non-treated control
we are seeing improvements with both the
safeguard
in particular the safeguard and the
prudent and again it's comparable to
our best apron maxim treatment as the
chemical seed treatment
this is where gary's laboratory was was
instrumental in supporting this project
we would see the symptoms in the field
as far as disease seedlings
his laboratory has done the
characterization
of what pathogens are associated with
those disease seedlings so we can see
here
in the picture on the the photo at the
bottom on the left
uh indicative of those testing positive
for fusarium species
they picture on the lower right having
pythium species present
gary's laboratory is still ongoing work
to characterize the species
of these along with other samples that
we have provided
to their lab as i said this is a
multi-state project and being a
multi-state project
is good in that we do not want to simply
have seeds that are tested in cornell
that only
have good control in the northeast so
we've expanded the testing we have
uh seed testing at virginia tech in the
southern region
and then north dakota state and the
north central region
again the same color coding in the same
uh scheme
as we had in our previous slides we see
safeguard and prudent
doing very well and this is from one
study we have there'll be one more study
coming with data this fall from virginia
tech
and then north dakota state in this case
we're seeing the chemical seed
treatments
doing quite well in this one across the
board
but still we're seeing for example
safeguard doing a nice job
so we're we're gathering information now
in the
very good picture is that we're seeing
some
consistency in our results
from field to field and from
location to location within the regions
of the united states so let's go ahead
and summarize where we're at with this
our biochemical seed treatments the
safeguard which was the
organic copper and the prudent which is
a phosphite
had good efficacy in all the studies the
data that we have in hand
at this point in time the chemical seed
treatments apron xl and maxim still
had good efficacy and again these are
tried and true
chemical seed treatments that are widely
labeled
unfortunately after two years of work
where syngenta
was initially very interested in this
project
syngenta is no longer providing support
for hemp
on any particular application so it
could be syngenta herbicides
and things like that they're not going
to be supporting those hemp labels the
united states which is
is a big setback so we really need other
chemical seed treatments from another
company to test and we're looking into
that at this time
finally the biologicals and we've done
now two years in a row trying to test
a good range of commercially available
and used biological seed treatments
simply were not effective in our study
to control
damping off
so i want to thank people first of all
in my laboratory
hillary mayton hillary kind of
headed up all the field studies that you
had as well as gathering data
from the other states
and then summarizing some of the data in
the graphs that you're seeing
michael loose in my laboratory has done
all the seed
treatment application a lot of the
in-house testing as far as germination
soil testing and i saw a bio assay
massey's done a lot of the photographic
work and other support work for this
project so
very nice team that i'm very fortunate
to have people
working with me on this project in
gary's laboratory
jen starr was really instrumental in
working
with hillary taking those field samples
and doing the characterization
and kevin and gary's lab is helping at
the molecular characterization
so we know what species are involved
again we work very closely with the
company registrants in other words the
companies that
actually are producing these we're
working directly with our r
d people to make sure that we're testing
the best
biological chemical biochemical
treatment that they would have available
for this project and finally i want to
thank
support from ir4 but in particular for
new york ag and markets for their
continued support
for this and for other cornell hemp
projects
thank you very much
okay thanks very much alan we are going
to move on now
because we have three short
presentations
from some of my colleagues in cornell
cooperative extension
talking about their work on the
economics and supply chains
starting with john hanchak
good morning my name is john hanchar i
am with cornell university and a member
of the cornell university hemp group
that is stunning hemp production in new
york state
lindsey paschall and mary ulrich also
with cornell university and i have been
doing research and extension work
on the economic aspects of growing hemp
in new york
lindsay mary and i will be presenting
update type information from an
economics perspective
based upon our cost of production work i
will describe the economic environment
the market signals which growers
considered earlier in the year
regarding planting decisions lindsay
will then provide update information for
processing retail and consumer
activities
mary will discuss what do growers need
to be thinking of
to obtain viable hemp enterprises
cost of production and expected prices
are key determinants of growers planting
decisions
should i produce or not if production
makes sense then how much
should i plan to supply at expected
prices
acreage and production input decisions
are involved
item one figure one contains information
produced by cornell
university and others for cornell
university resources
please see hemp.kales.cornell.edu
analysis for a plastic culture system
suggests variable costs and total costs
equal twelve thousand
six hundred and thirteen thousand one
hundred dollars per acre
respectively the cornell work excludes a
charge for the value of management
inputs required
and reflects pre-planting inputs tasks
to the point where dry
material is in totes ready for immediate
delivery
or ready for storage in future delivery
item two the other studies
use similar cost to production methods
but the items included in time periods
considered differed
for example the university of
connecticut values
include a charge for management inputs
required
various marketing expenses and others
variable costs for the five study ranged
from
eight thousand eight hundred dollars to
thirteen thousand four hundred dollars
per acre
the five study average was twelve
thousand two hundred dollars per acre
for the variable cost measure total
costs ranged from nine thousand two
hundred dollars
to nineteen thousand three hundred
dollars
per acre the five study average was
fourteen thousand dollars per acre
item three calculated break-even prices
the expected prices received that would
cover variable
and total cost using the five study
averages
equaled 1.31 and 1.51
dollars per percent cbd per pound of dry
matter
respectively given percent cbd
equals six dry matter per plant equal
one pound
and harvested plants per acre equal one
thousand
five hundred fifty plants
expected prices for the two thousand
twenty growing in harvest year
late 2019 of about a dollar
in early 2020 about
65 cents relative to cost suggests a
relatively unfavorable economic
environment
for hemp cbd
item four in summary
there are three aspects that this
information supports
and unvei unfavorable economic
environment unfavorable market signals
was being considered by growers as they
made
planting decisions early in the year
especially when compared to expectations
for alternative horticulture crops
risks and uncertainties still concern
growers a comment by mary ulrich
cce eastern new york horticulture
program
during a recent cornell university hemp
check-in call
summarizes the environment quite well
activity
that is hemp production is a fraction of
what it was last year
in the area
if you have questions or comments you
can contact me john hanchar
at jjh6 cornell.edu
thank you thanks john
can move on to lindsey paschall's
presentation
hi my name is lindsay pacio and i'm on
cornell cooperative extension's harvest
new york team i will be discussing the
supply chain for industrial hemp in new
york state
with discussions about stated processors
a little bit about retailers and
consumers
in may 2020 a survey was sent out to the
hemp processors
in new york state to find out what the
state of hemp
processing happened in 2019 out of a
little over a hundred
processors in new york state only 24
responded
13 said that they did process hemp in
new york state
and 11 said that they did not
we asked how much hemp did you process
in 2019 um
11 respondents did not process any hemp
and then the hemp range between 0 and
28 278 pounds
with a total of 122 088 pounds
processed in new york state according to
the
um respondents
in 2019 um we asked
what the minimum cbd content that hemp
process required
from their growers it ranged anywhere
from zero to 12 percent
of cbd percentage they would like from
growers
then we asked processors what their
processing happened to
this included hemp oil seed cake
biofuel plastic raw materials hemp fiber
pellets and that was for pellet stoves
extracts such as powders base oil
protein tinctures flower and cbd
in 2020
we wanted to know what processors were
looking at for their capacity
for processing hemp and you know the
range is
kind of all of the board but included
weekly basis of 200 pounds
some processors said for a month they
could only do about two acres or
anywhere between
a thousand and 140 000 pounds
um with also some processors responding
that they could do anywhere from 6 000
to a million pounds
within the year
there's not a lot of information out
there in new york state about the state
of
retailers and consumers this will
probably be
potentially a future survey for to find
out from
retailers consumers where the industry
is
there's a lot of predictions online
about how
um retail stores might end up closing
because of cobit 19.
you know a lot of people can buy cbd
locally
or they can buy it online so the retail
side is very unpredictable
um and so is on the consumer side
there's large predictions that
cbd consumption will continue to
increase between 2020 and 2024
if you have any other questions about
hemp processors in your state please
feel free to reach out to me my email
address is
lep67 cornell.edu
good afternoon i'm mary ulrich with
quinoa cooperative extension in orange
county
i two am on the hemp team and i'm going
to address a little bit about risk and
reward because of course the question
this year is the reward of hemp the
potential for
profit balance out with the risk
because those two things should be in
direct
proportion to one another but they may
not be
and so has hemp and all rainbows and
kittens
or is it a little wild westy i've seen a
lot of wild westy out there in the last
couple of years
and so i'm going to address a couple of
ways to protect yourself from
the bad actors and other potential
negatives that
occur so how's risk measured and
mitigated you know we use cost of
production data
john mentioned that it's coming along
but the future market certainly is
questionable we certainly do need more
of uh more interest from consumers to
keep that price
up to keep the demand up we also
mitigate risk with crop insurance
i don't know what the payments i haven't
talked to anybody who
signed up for crop insurance and i mean
the usda
fsa crop insurance
so i don't know what those payments are
going to be for 2020.
my prediction last year was that they
were either going to be really good or
really bad and so we'll see what happens
with them
i'm always curious to talk to people
who've had insurance so if you've had
insurance please
give me a ring because private or the
federal government supported ones
that would be i'd love that information
so and also one way to protect yourself
or to
mitigate risk is to have a contract and
of course with the 2018 farm bill
going to be brought into effect in new
york state by the end of the year
there's lots of changes in the landscape
happening and of course we're not used
to
legislation changing so quickly around
crops but the last few years this has
been
quite a little roller coaster so that in
itself is a risk that you don't know
where things are going to go
legislatively of course the big
force measure or the big risk is that
fda may decide to
regulate the crop particularly in the
case of cbd
and that could have a huge impact
on markets production if fda said no no
this is a drug and everybody has to have
just like a drug everybody has to have
the same kind of testing and monitoring
then there would be a lot of producers
and processors
that would no longer have a market
because they couldn't meet those
requirements
and so the other thing i just want to
say about contracts you know if it
sounds too good to be
true it probably is and
i'm going to show you a flyer in a
minute that
can help you out in terms of contracts
so what's the biggest thing that i see
as a problem with hemp
contracts or hemp relationships right
now
is that there's no collective knowledge
you know we
for produce we have the blue book so the
people can go look up buyers in new york
state
buyers are bonded so that if
a seller doesn't get paid they can go to
the state and get reimbursed through
that bonding process
if you know they really didn't get paid
for something that they sold and
everything was supposed to be okay
and the seller just didn't get their
money
there's a way to get it back but in hemp
that doesn't exist right now
and there's no institutional memory
which we should have
or we have in other businesses you know
who is going to pay you you know who the
traditional bad actors are you know the
guys who pay in 30 60 90 and the ones
who don't
if you don't know your neighbors do and
so sharing information about that
and other crops has been very open and
hemp it has not been so
even what little institutional memory is
being gathered
it's not being shared and so it seems
like
bad actors are going from farm to farm
or from region to region
and causing trouble and certainly this
isn't just about cbd
i've had it happen that folks selling
grain came to me
because they didn't get paid for their
grain because the buyer said
that it was moldy but didn't was moldy
until like three months later
so there's no way to trace back whose
fault that was it was just very
um unfortunate and so also very unusual
relationships between
value and cost that the farmer needs to
buy into the processing somehow
which is really you know not the case
ocean spray
you know really doesn't need the farmers
necessarily
to buy into the processing part itself
they might be a co-op
in terms of selling but do they own the
equipment
maybe not or orange juice companies or
any of those
there isn't that same kind of need to be
involved
there's a lot of interest from people
who have never been involved in
agriculture
that can be a little bit of a problem
there's also what i call the billionaire
rule there's a lot of folks running
around saying oh i have billionaire
friends well unless you see a picture of
him with
warren buffett like on his christmas
card don't believe it
so one of the local growers actually
said if it's a good party it'll still be
going in a couple of years
and if it's a bad party i never wanted
to go in the first place
he said that one question about why he
was because he was going to grow and
then
changed his mind in the last minute and
19
and so just um using caution
so to try and um
more closely at some of those contract
details there's this
uh six page pamphlet the first two pages
are about production stuff but then the
next four about contracts
i wrote it with the assistance of
several attorneys agricultural attorneys
and so uh just have a look at that it's
on both the cornell website
and the hemp blog which here's the pages
and so the blog is on the left
that's what it looks like and so there's
regular news updates there
and updates for meetings and things like
that there's also the link for the
contract thing
and on the right don't forget that
cornell has its own website
and then the team whether it's other
people you've heard from today
or john or lindsay or myself all of our
contact information is also on there on
the team website
okay thanks very much john lindsey
and mary uh we're running a little bit
over time
and i see chris logue is there ready to
make his presentation so what i'm going
to suggest if people can
stay on is we will extend
our q a session uh that will start at
around 11 55
beyond 12 o'clock if people can stay on
so you can ask questions to john lindsay
and mary
but now i would like to move on uh to
chris lowe
director of plant industry at new york
state department of ag and markets
chris you have the floor thanks larry
can you hear me okay
yep sounds great excellent trying a
new headset today uh so good morning
everybody and uh
the first thing i really should should
say is uh
thank you very much larry for having us
here today
uh to talk with you and you know i want
to compliment you on a
on a fantastic um
program today uh and also the fantastic
uh research program and the great
communication on industrial hemp
uh back and forth with the department as
well as
with uh the growers in new york state
as well as in other states um
you know everybody everybody uh should
have received a letter or all of our
uh registered research partners should
have received
a letter via email uh earlier this week
that letter should also be making its
way through the postal service as well
we wanted to be sure that we sent that
out multiple ways so that
folks would would get the message as
quick as possible
we really spent the last six or eight
months here in the department
uh working on and looking at
uh what the requirements of the 2018
farm bill program were
uh as many of you uh you know know we
sent in
uh comments on the uh federal interim
rule
uh you all sent in many comments there's
a lot of commonality among those
comments and
identified a number of barriers related
to
hemp for growers going forward under the
2018 rules
as well as four states going forward
under the 2018 rules
we had an informal deadline with usda
ams the states did as far as
submitting plans for consideration
that deadline was august 15th uh we were
deliberating here
uh within the agency and outside the
agency
uh frankly right up until uh that august
15th deadline
about uh what direction to go in
uh our decision at that time was
uh that we
were unable to submit a compliant plan
to usda
which sets the stage for usda to be
the regulatory authority for hemp here
in new york state
um the authority of the 2014 farm bill
uh which is what we're operating on
right now uh you all know expires on 10
31
2020. it's our intention to
run a 2014 compliant program up until
that
uh sunsets in october of this year's
of this year excuse me that federal
interim rule
uh has many aspects that are uh
inconsistent with what we believe the
congressional intent was uh when the
2018
farm bill was passed we think that
intent was
uh in line with what our beliefs here in
new york have been which is to consider
that
industrial hemp is an agricultural
commodity
and uh that the farm bill was really to
you know continue to stimulate and
develop the industry
some of the things that we found uh
particularly difficult to deal with
were the testing requirements and the
destruction requirements
there's a number of other other issues
that we and
others including growers in new york and
other states
have identified that are problematic
we feel that the interpretation of this
section of the farm bill and the
corresponding sections of the federal
interim rule
uh really show that they've been
most likely heavily influenced by
department of justice in the dea
had a number of conversations over the
past several months with usda
regarding what the legal boundaries are
for
a state hemp program
and what could or would be approved in a
hemp plan and what the required
regulatory activities would be
in the final analysis uh the components
of an approved state plan are
essentially the same as federal
oversight of the program
in short the rules are the same after
1031 whether
the state or the federal government is
the primary authority
and states that that sign on for
being the primary regulatory authority
are really
operating as agents if you will of the
federal
government our feeling is that
submission of a compliant plan
really uh is an affirmation that the
state agrees with the federal interim
rule and it certainly legally obligates
us to carry out the plan
is submitted um submitting a compliant
plan
with the intent of of not
following it really is is uh in our
opinion a disingenuous act
um and we think that by not submitting a
plan to usda
new york state is really sending a clear
message to usda
that the requirements are unworkable and
unnecessarily burdensome to the states
and the growers uh we feel as though
there are several states that are on the
cusp of
uh following us in this action of not
sending in a plan
and uh not at liberty right now to
to name particular states that are
considering this we need to
uh respect their sovereignty and respect
their decision-making process in that
but we do believe that you'll see some
other states that that take this action
as well going forward
i want to transition a little bit to the
letters that we sent to usda
as well as the ones that we sent out to
our research partners
they both letters reference our strong
commitment to hemp and new york state
we as a department as an agency and i
think
as a state government we're all still
very much committed to hemp
as well as as its economic potential for
new york farmers
i was very interested to see and hear
the economic analysis
that john hanchar and uh lindsay and
mary presented earlier here today
um and i saw some of the comments in the
in the chat box
uh i think it's uh i think
the uh this industry is is having
growing pains clearly
but it still clearly has a lot of
potential for new york producers as well
as others
um so where are we right now so
getting back to our commitment to
growers we uh
you know stand ready to assist our hemp
growers with the transition to
federal licensing structure we want to
have that be in the most
uh seamless and orderly way possible
we're going to do
everything in our control to make this
happen
one thing that i think is is really been
a fantastic thing about the hemp program
here in new york and i think in
other parts of the country and it's a
and it's a real positive thing
is the enthusiasm and the
entrepreneurship
um and what we've seen in new york is uh
that enthusiasm and entrepreneurship
really
has led to a lot of um
you know specific nuances in your
business
um you know that's a great thing that
some of those nuances perhaps uh
complicate the transition
over to the usda program but we are
certainly going to
work with you to get you into that
program
in the best way possible with the
least legal and
financial risk we're going to also
continue to advocate for adjustments in
the federal program in a more flexible
regulatory
structure
so a couple things uh just to talk a
little bit about
some general information with the
transition over to
the federal side of things one thing
that
again is a really positive is that
actually one of our staff
people here at the department uh
took a position with the usda program
and so we have really a very strong
relationship with the folks at ams
because of that and we also have a
really good communications with
the folks at ams uh because of that
connection with our former staff person
so we've had some initial conversations
about what we think this looks like
um so just a couple of general things
that we're working on and again
there are a lot of specific questions
that need to be answered
and um we're going to work through those
over the next
uh weeks to help you out but just a
typical field grower as we've had the
conversation
with usda that typical field grower
should probably plan on having their
harvest complete
by by the end of the 2014
farm bill authority and then
proceed to register with the usda
once you're registered with the usda
you're going to be subject to the
federal requirements
our understanding is is that you cannot
have the federal license and the state
registration at the same time
you also want to have all of your
testing of the current year's crop
done and in hand before that happens
so the complicating factors are going to
be places that uh
are growing plants for planting or
perhaps that have their plants
in greenhouses and we're going to work
closely with those folks
um couple things on sampling so the usda
program does not require the sampler or
the lab at this point to be dea
registered at this time i think in the
original version
of the interim rule they did have that
requirement
uh we think this potentially creates
some opportunity for some service
providers in the state
whether they be soil and water
conservation folks or certified crop
advisors or perhaps organic certifiers
to help out with the sampling
requirements and we're told that there
are some good training resources for
potential samplers on the usda website
a little bit here quickly on the federal
application process and reporting under
the federal program
uh the first step in the federal process
is going to be
to get your fbi background check you
have to have that
in hand at the time of application it
can be no older than 60 days old when
it's submitted to the usda
um i'm told that usda
is having some interactions with new
york growers that
uh some of the issues around the postal
service right now
um are creating a little bit of a a
delay
in background checks there is a
web-based service
that can do a background check which is
a
i'm told more expensive i think it's
fifty dollars rather than eighteen
dollars
but we'll try to get that information
linked up on our website soon
once you've got the apple or the
background check and plan
in hand i should say you would fill out
your
application it's a one-pager there is no
fee associated with that application
uh it would get submitted to usda
and we're in conversations with usda
about
whether those applications should become
coming in right now
or whether they should be held until
november 1st
one of the things that that is a
factor in this is as other states
make a similar decision to what the
decision that we made here
uh their licensing volume is going to
increase
either way what we think will happen is
that the licenses on the federal side
will be issued with an effective date of
november 1st 2020.
so once the license is reviewed or the
application is reviewed on the federal
side the app
successful applicant is going to receive
the license document
and then you would need to go to the
local usda
fsa service center to
register your uh specific
production locations i'm told that that
information
uh is going to then be shared
with uh law enforcement authorities
um you know my experience with fsa
is that they have very robust gis
capabilities and so that may
actually result in some better
communication
with um with law enforcement
so a couple things where we'll still be
involved
here uh at ag markets certainly
um we still see a very strong role for
us here
around uh the issues around seed quality
seed certification
um you know we've talked quite a bit
with some of the seed suppliers
about being in compliance with the seed
laws
we'll also be working continue continue
to work on plant health and plant
quality
issues if you're a producer who is
selling
hemp transplants to other entities you
would continue to
maintain your nursery grower
registration with us you would continue
to have
an inspection uh once per two year
licensing cycle
you know to document the the health of
the plant material coming out of your
operation
so uh we still have a long list of
questions to answer
again i want to reaffirm the commitment
we have to all of you um
i know following you know my con my
presentation here
of my comments here we've got uh one of
my colleagues pat
with the department of health who's
going to talk about where we're going on
processing
and you know please keep in mind we're
here to
to help you and to make this transition
as
as pain free and easy
as possible so i appreciate it i also
want to appreci
say that i appreciate very much uh you
know the great way that all of our field
staff and inspectors have been treated
by this
industry um it's been a real pleasure
uh working with all of you we'll
continue to work with you and help you
in any way that we can
and uh as always we're here for you
thank you thanks very much chris
uh and again it has been a great
research partnership
with new york state ag markets we hope
to find a way to continue that
i will say that
your name is still listed on the usda
ams website as the contact for new york
state
so i sent an email this morning to usda
to try to find out
who our contact will be with usda
in new york state when we have questions
but yeah a lot of the questions in the
chat box right now
refer to the future of cbd processing
and processing licensing
uh so i am just going to move right on
to pat mckeech from department of health
and he can describe what the future of
cbd processing regulations will be in
new york state
pat great thank you uh
can you hear me okay yep sounds great
awesome so uh my name is pat mccage and
i work for the
new york state department of health and
i'm part of a team here
setting up the cannabinoid hemp program
and
as chris was uh i'd like to echo what
chris was saying
this has been absolutely phenomenal uh
presentation this morning
learned so much and so thank you to
larry for for inviting us and
allowing us to kind of give an update on
on the the cannabinoid hemp program
here um unfortunately uh we were hoping
that the regulations were going to be
out by now
so uh we could kind of get a little bit
more into the meat and potatoes of what
the program will look like
but uh we are being told that they're at
the last stage
of approval so we're hoping they'll be
out within the next couple weeks here
which will kind of give a clearer
picture of everything that
will be in the program um i also want to
highlight
that uh there's a public comment period
associated with those regulations
so um you know you guys are obviously
you know involved in the industry
studying the industry experts and hemp
and and uh what's kind of the cutting
edge movement now
and we definitely encourage encourage
you guys to submit comments
because uh you know we're not gonna get
everything right the the first time
and uh viewing this more as a
partnership
will definitely help us help us make the
best you know cannabinoid hemp program
we can um and i think we're up to now
what 16 different states
that have their own unique kind of uh
cannabinoid hemp or cbd regulations out
there
so it really is a rapidly developing
regulatory framework right now there's a
patchwork of different states
and we borrowed a little bit from others
we borrowed a little bit from the
dietary supplement industry from the
food regulations
and uh we're hoping hoping just to make
something that works
and is flexible so
getting started uh today just want to
talk a little bit about the
legislative background kind of the
history of how how the bill came to pass
and um why it was kind of placed at the
at the department of health
medical marijuana program and we'll go
over the program objectives
for what we're trying to accomplish here
a brief description of the different
license types between processors and
retailers
um look at the product standards that
we're trying to trying to hold these two
and
really those are really building off of
the great work that ag
markets has already done and then a
quick timeline
and next steps so we can kind of
telegraph what the next three to six
months will look like
so as many of you are probably aware a
bill passed in in early 2020
establishing
a hemp program in new york state and as
uh chris just just mentioned in the last
uh segment there
uh the usda will actually be the uh
regulating cultivation
for the 2021 uh grow season due to kind
of
the cumbersome requirements with the
interim final rule
and then the processing and retailing of
cannabinoid hemp
will be going over to the department of
health
now uh it was really placed there to
kind of build off the expertise
that had been developed from regulating
the medical marijuana program
there's a lot of synergies in terms of
how the plant is extracted
packaging labeling requirements
manufacturing requirements
testing so we figured it would be a good
place to kind of
merge and you know always thinking about
the taxpayer uh sharing some resources
here
so we can can um
get a get a good head start and i want
to
uh highlight this first sub bullet here
about the transition from a research
program to a traditional license program
because it it is really significant um
when again markets first developed their
program back in 2015
it was really you know focused on what
we heard today in research
and then all of a sudden cbd exploded
and everyone wanted to grow it everyone
wanted to process it and it became much
more about the
the marketability in the
commercialization aspects
of of hemp which which is great but
under a research program you're kind of
limited
in in the sort of uh relationship
between the regulator
and the licensee so so uh under this new
framework we're hoping that we can
really uh
grow and help develop the hemp industry
in new york state
so what are we talking about uh
cannabinoid hemp um
hemp is defined as any product that is
used for its cannabinoid content for
human consumption or topical application
so hemp seed oil hemp protein powder
uh those are you know gris they're
regulated as food they would still be
under egg and markets purview
um and industrial applications
and you know bioplastics textiles that's
not part of the scope of the program
either
we're really focused on things that are
being sold for their cannabinoid content
and being you know ingested in the human
body or applied to the skin
um and also want to highlight that it
was a conscious choice to use
cannabinoid
rather than calling it the cpd program
you know i think
we heard from the panels this morning
you know cbg is getting big
uh terpenes and those come up
daily uh i'm not going to comment on it
but we're
getting or i'm seeing a bunch of
articles about delta 8 thc
and uh what the 2004 18 farm bill might
have done to
impact that so um it's always
interesting
to be involved in this industry
so what we're really trying to do here
at the department of health in terms of
objectives is is the first one here is
we just want to comprehensively regulate
cannabinoid hemp products in new york
state
so when we were drafting the regulations
and we were talking with people in the
industry or just people
kind of in new york state there's so
much ambiguity
right now and because of the lack of
federal guidance
that some of the most common questions
are just like what's allowed and what's
not allowed
so that's definitely one of the main
main focuses of the program is just
trying to provide a clear
baseline of what will be allowed in new
york state
the second bullet point here is
definitely a huge pillar especially for
us at the department of health
um you know consumer protection and
quality control standards
are a huge huge aspect of the program we
want to make sure that
products on the shelf have been tested
are labeled properly and manufactured to
a certain standard
and give and give consumers some
assurance
that when they're buying something it
actually contains
cannabinoids they're not getting ripped
off and and they have you know the
appropriate warnings or disclosures of
what's in the bottle
and kind of tied into that is is this
last point about education and
enforcement
so we we definitely understand that you
know you can have the best rules in the
world
but if people aren't following them or
they're not being uh
enforced it doesn't really matter so uh
education
enforcement are going to be a really key
pillar of the program and
um we're small now but we're hoping that
we can ramp up
in terms of resources over the next few
years and dedicate a lot of a lot of
a lot of those resources to that effort
so a quick overview of the license types
in the new program
we split the processor into two
different licenses so
there's the extraction and manufacturing
license
and then the manufacturing only license
uh the the key difference here
is really um the extractor license
because
you know you're using different
equipment and different technologies
and there's a different level of risk
for extraction that that is going to be
its own
kind of a license type assuming that not
every business will want to do that
and then the manufacturing only license
will be businesses who are purchasing
kind of that intermediary product that's
already been extracted so your isolates
distillates
whole plant extracts and then
manufacturing a product from there
so really just the idea there was just
allowing different
opportunities for businesses to to enter
enter the supply chain
uh based on their business model
and the last uh license here is the hemp
retailer license
um our idea here is really to make it
more of a permit or a registration
this is just a way for the department to
kind of get some insight into where
these products are being sold
um and then also gets our foot in the
door so we can start educating these
retailers about you know how to source
a quality cannabinoid hemp product what
to look for on the label has it been
tested
does it say how many milligrams of cbd
are in it
and uh from there you know we'll have a
piece of paper that says
well you agreed that you were going to
check for the x y and z and you're not
so that'll kind of help us on the
enforcement side as well
and again you know there's potentially
10 000 uh places in new york state
that could be selling uh cannabinoid
products
uh within the first year
so uh the product standards for for
those of you who are research
partnership research partners in the ag
markets program right now
a lot of these bullet points should look
really familiar
thank you chris for for creating a great
program over there we we
plagiarized copied and stole a lot of
good ideas from that program
so uh in regards to manufacturing um you
know
we don't want to reinvent the wheel here
uh there's already
uh good regulations out there in terms
of good manufacturing processes for both
food and dietary supplements
and we kind of want to build off that as
a foundation
and then layer on those additional um
concerns
uh that are unique to cannabis so uh
packaging and labeling is a great
example
um because this is such a new industry
um
it's all about consumer awareness we
want to make sure the consumer
knows what they're putting in their body
how much they're they're
uh consuming uh there's a qr code so
they can they can check that
the product has been tested it's been
labeled and then um
warnings and disclosures are also
extremely important especially when
you're talking about you know a full
spectrum product
that could potentially cause someone to
fail a drug test
you want to be upfront about that
information because that could affect
someone's life
so um we're looking to add things like
that
uh in regards to laboratory testing um
we're going with the 17025 iso
accreditation
another a couple other states are also
going with that
i think it's popular in in the medical
marijuana and adult use
industry as well so we're kind of
building off that and as these programs
grow
the quality of the third party lab
sector should also grow with
it so that'll be definitely a work in
progress
um we're requiring a full panel of
testing for cannabinoid hemp products
i mean similar to the medical marijuana
and the adult use standards
you know you're still putting it in your
body so it should be tested for
you know residual solvents microbials
heavy metals
etc
so that really is the the program in a
nutshell um
i want to highlight again that the
regulations should be out relatively
soon
uh we definitely encourage everyone to
give feedback on them
and i also want to highlight that they
are proposed regulations so
things will not be written in stone
we'll have opportunities to make changes
and um new licenses should be available
we're shooting for early 2021 for on the
both
the processor side and the retail side
so please be on the lookout for
additional information there
uh we're working on setting up a
cannabinoid hemp website
so we can post some of this stuff online
and also setting up
a call center number so we can we can
take your calls
we do have a shared email that's on my
next slide i can share that at the end
here
um but quickly the last point here is we
also are working in tandem with ag
markets
on the transition of existing research
partners over to the doh program
so uh we really want to make that as
seamless as possible as i already
mentioned a lot of the requirements will
be similar
so it'll kind of just be working out
those who are operating those who are
not operating and getting all the
boxes checked on the application to to
make it as seamless as possible
so once again thank you to cornell for
letting us give this
update um if you want to see if you want
to contact us we're more than happy
to answer questions the email is hemp
health.new york.gov
and uh thank you i will kick it back to
larry now
thanks very much pat uh we're very close
to
the uh scheduled uh time of completing
our field day but i want to go another
15 minutes or so to try to let uh
mainly you and chris answer some of
these questions if you can
uh one of the main questions i've seen
is
how will usda define a
grower or a producer is that the
landowner or
would it be
someone who's renting the land for
example chris you have a
an idea i'm not sure i can answer that
so
so larry i think my sense is is that
it's going to be
very similar to how we defined it um and
again this is
these are all details that um
that we need to work through with them
but my sense is it's
the farmer is registered with them
um and then the locations you know get
registered through farm service
agency yeah
uh dan is asking who needs to have the
fbi
uh identity history summary uh
my reading of that was it was the
principles of the firm
right i would agree with that yep
uh so not necessarily uh all of the
staff
or investors and of course at cornell
university we are in discussion with our
general counsel because the principal of
cornell university is our president
and our board of trustees yep i think we
i think we cross that bridge ourselves
on that a while
ago right between state and cornell
so i just got an email from our general
counsel saying
larry you're gonna apply as an
individual right
uh another question that has come up
quite a bit
from pat and we get this question quite
a bit is uh
will department of health be regulating
uh smokable flour
how what will the regulation of that
look like
under the doh program yeah so i
i will make the caveat that our
regulations are not
are not final yet so this is all subject
to change and even when they're posted
they're still subject to change but at
the time we are we are
uh looking for a pathway to allow flower
however
um we are going to restrict the
the uh forms that can be sold so no
pre-rolls
no hemp cigars no cigarettes and that's
really done from a public health
perspective to not really encourage the
combustion of these products
and then recognizing that you know they
are available in other states and online
and um there's also other uses
such as amputees and throwing them in
flour making your own edibles at home
so uh at this time that is the direction
we're heading
uh but please be on the lookout for
those final regulations
another question i think for chris
although maybe not a
division of plant industry question uh
can we extend
our new york grown and certified status
to our hemp crop
and cannabinoid products so
uh not a plant industry question larry i
would have to kick that to
um one of our folks in ag development
and
certainly can uh can try to get an
answer to that for you
i think i've seen questions regarding
uh holding material after november 1st
so will you need to be licensed with
usda
to hold let's say dried material
certainly if you have clones growing in
your greenhouse
on november 1st as we will have
we need to have a usda license but what
about
tested harvested material so
we've actually as we've been kind of uh
participating in this webinar today
we've been
having some uh side conversations with
usda with some of those questions and
we're gonna try to get a
firm answer on that um the initial
answer we have on that is
is that anything that is you know
out of the ground harvested tested
before october 31st should be to the
uh to the state standard anything
that you know is still in the ground and
the testing and such is not completed
by october 31st goes to the to the
federal standard i think one of the
things that we really need to get a bead
on
larry is you know i know there's some
product out there that has been stored
for a longer period of time
that you know folks are are waiting
frankly for uh
better market conditions and we need to
get a sense of that because
i'm not sure uh well
i know that our former staff person who
now works for usda understands that
i'm not sure people higher up the chain
in usda
have a sense of that so we can work on
that one
yeah uh pat here's there's a question
can you talk about the application
process for retailers
yeah definitely so we're actually we're
in the process now of uh developing an
online application for that
uh trying to make it kind of as easy as
possible it's not meant to be really a
barrier of entry
and uh is really more of a permit a
registration
at which uh you can kind of just get an
idea of where these
places are being sold and then um can
provide some education to them and
similar to the processor licenses we're
hoping to roll that out in early 2021
great
there's a question what will the
mechanism of enforcement be
for non-compliant hemp products in new
york state
beginning in 21.
that's a question for you pat howard how
is doh
going to enforce all of these new
regulations
that's a great question and we are
definitely working through that now
right here
um like i said i think the first year
will really be focused on education
and trying to get people understanding
what the new rules and regulations are
we understand that a lot of these people
have have product that they've already
purchased in anticipation you know for
the next six months
so uh there will be some some type of
grace period there for stuff that's on
the shelves now
um and then from there i think it's you
know we're going to take best practices
from from ag
markets and what we learned in the
medical marijuana industry in terms of
uh you know testing products doing
random sampling
uh secret shopping stuff like that to
kind of make sure that
things are properly labeled and
manufactured yeah
there have been a lot of comments about
the
uh federal limits or
compliance limits for thc uh
folks should know that the national farm
bureau federation
is lobbying congress for a one percent
total thc limit as well as many of the
uh hemp industry groups if you are not a
member
of hemp industry association or other
uh national hemp uh associations
uh now may be a good time to consider
joining some of those
uh to because they are they are involved
in that advocacy
uh there was a question
uh chris if folks are only one year into
their license
will they get a refund so
uh that's a great question larry
unfortunately
you know that that's an application fee
uh that we had with this program and
and we are not going to be in the
position to to prorate those licenses
uh so question for pat will existing
research partner processors be
grandfathered into the doh
doh program what would be the transition
for existing license holders
yes so we've been uh we actually started
the outreach uh about a month ago
to kind of do a level set and we're
working with ag and markets now
to kind of get a good snapshot of kind
of where everyone is in the process
we understand that you know cove really
threw a wrench into a lot of people
setting up their facilities and getting
all their extraction equipment ready and
stuff like that
so our goal here at doh is really to
work with all the research partners
to help them transition as seamless as
possible
everyone will have to apply under a new
license
because it is a new program but um we're
hoping to really spell that out
and make it make it as easy as possible
to kind of shift over
so uh you know people who are in
operation can continue and those who are
still setting up will understand the new
requirements
and can hit the ground running
yeah i think there's a similar question
for folks who will need to transition
from the state program to the federal
program when should they start
we've got just a little bit more than
two months now
i started filling out my application
this morning
and looking at the fbi identity history
summary check there is a big notice here
on the website that
if you submit that via mail the current
processing time
is 12 weeks there is an
online process that they say will only
take four to five days
but if you are currently a grower and
will need a grower's license on november
1st
i would encourage you to get that
paperwork in
quickly so and larry if i can jump in
here real quick on that because i see
those
those uh questions in the chat as well
um
we're we're in conversations with usda
on how best to do this
and um you know there's there
there could be a scenario where
they hold applications uh
and then uh you know they would if they
if they were holding them in other words
if they got my application today they
would take a look at it
they would determine whether it was
complete or not
if it was incomplete they'd return it
they would then uh
perhaps hold it until the end of october
issue the registration
with a couple of other states that that
frankly are
are bigger in hemp production than new
york
on the cusp of of making similar
decisions that we made
they're thinking that they don't want to
get backed up and what they may do
is to um you know start accepting
uh those applications acting on them and
actually issuing the license document
with a november first
effective date so what i would would ask
is um that folks uh
allow us to have a little bit more
conversation with usda
and see how they want to handle this
um you know as a as a administrator who
who faced the tidal wave of of 2017
and 2018 uh uh you know i still want to
maintain a uh respectful and
collegial relationship with with usda
particularly since
uh you know one of their key staff
people worked for me and
i have a lot of respect for for her
personally as well so
um so let us work this a little bit
um i don't see the answers to these
types of questions
uh as far as timing of applications
taking
particularly long and so if we had even
a week or so to kind of work through
that and then get that information
up on our website as well as being able
to distribute it through your
lists i think that would be super yeah
yeah i will say that uh at a recent
national conference i was involved in
bill hoffman who was running the usda
program
i would say was conflicted because he
wants to serve the interest
interests of the farmers uh but is bound
by the rule-making process
at usda uh so
uh i i hope they will they will maintain
that
that attitude of keeping the interest of
farmers i
i have to say despite our
clear policy differences here bill
is seems to be a very um
you know a very thoughtful person and i
think really wants to see this industry
grow and uh i think he can be a strong
advocate for it
but again he's you know i i've con
i've i've compared his situation to
where we were
in the state in 2015 and 2016
when we put our first reg in place which
if you remember had
the requirements for the security fences
and was going to cost everybody 50 60
000
an acre to comply with their you know
give them some time to work through this
just a couple of final notes here in the
regulations
there is an application window to usda
[Music]
that would close on october 31st so
again
get going on your application uh
and uh there's a comment here that uh
the fbi check did come back quickly i
think that's if you do it
online uh any final comments
pat or chris because we're going to wrap
this up here
just that
excited to keep the dialogue going you
know please email us there
if we're happy to work together on this
and make the best program we can
thank you yeah larry thanks for the
opportunity today and i appreciate the
thoughtful questions from the
participants as well as
uh again how how respectful
everybody has been of our staff here in
albany as well as the folks we've got
out working in the field
appreciate it yep thanks very much to
you chris and to pat as well as to our
other panelists
john lindsay and mary uh again
when you have questions uh they're your
first point of contact cornell
cooperative extension they're
they're very knowledgeable i've been
building the knowledge base in new york
state for three years now
uh so i really uh want to thank everyone
for joining us we we hit about 270
attendees at the peak uh so we had
pretty
broad impact uh nationally as well
uh so i want to thank again all of our
speakers and panelists
and thank you for attending
we look forward to hopefully an
in-person
or a hybrid in-person and online field
day
in 2021. thanks very much everyone
thank you larry well done
this has been a production of cornell
university
on the web at cornell.edu